We're live!
Man, fuck this shit.
No, fuck you!
Oh my god, Zeller.
Bro, how do I, how do I fucking, how do I, how do I- We're live!
We're live!
How do I skip the tutorial on this shit, man?
Fuck this shit, bro.
I'm so, I'm so done.
Wait, just like that we're live?
Yeah, just like that we're live!
Yes, we said no waiting room.
We're live.
Everything's live now.
Alright, how are we gonna start the story of why RPR is late?
I don't know.
So RPR couldn't get the store preference- Bro, shut up!
Wait, my OBS is fucked.
Wait, what?
Are you streaming your POV as well?
What, am I not allowed to or what?
No, you are but I'm just surprised you are!
Okay, so, so we had a lot of issues getting Zeller the game.
We had a lot of issues with that.
Yeah, no!
I had it all prepared!
You were not prepared, okay?
Come on guys, back me up on this.
I was prepared, right?
You were not prepared.
No, I was!
And then technical difficulties...
10 minutes before we were supposed to start, you were like, I just finished the tutorial.
No, that was 30 minutes before the stream.
Please be... please.
He did sound all like happy.
Like, oh I finished the tutorial guys.
Yes!
That's what I'm saying.
And then suddenly, you know, had some technical difficulties.
So I was like, oh shit!
I need to re-download the game, right?
Yeah, yeah.
And then, yeah, but then I apparently had to buy it again and stuff.
And then, uh, store preferences and vision lock and all that.
So I ended up spending like $200 trying to buy this game and get it again.
Yeah.
It did not work.
He tried to buy a Steam gift card and it didn't work either.
Yeah, exactly.
It didn't work.
Steam lost him out from buying it after that.
Yep.
He's like, you've been trying to purchase too many times.
You can't buy nothing.
So I was like, what the fuck am I gonna do?
So then finally I had to take it into my hands and then I actually made an entire email address, new account.
I purchased it on that account.
And then finally we were able to play.
How did you do it?
For God I Slave, thank God you exist.
Bro.
And then Han named it, Zeller is stupid.
NFC account.
What, you gonna look at me and tell me that I'm wrong?
Am I wrong?
You're not right!
Alright, how do we play this shit, guys?
What do we do?
Steam code.
Give me a Steam code.
Oh yeah, the Steam code.
Right, cause this is a brand new fucking account we have to make after all that stupid shit.
We have to fucking go through.
I can't handle you guys anymore.
You owe me dinner tonight, okay?
It's not my fault, man!
Probably two times, cause it was expensive.
Alright guys, I just need you guys to know, this is Zeller while more tamed than what he was off-stream.
Yeah, let's just say a couple guns would be handed out if you...
Just so you guys know, this is Zeller while he's restrained right now.
Oh yeah, you know me.
You know how it is.
All I'm saying is you're paying for dinner, bro.
I don't give a fuck.
Fuck off!
What did you do, man?
You did nothing!
I don't fuck the fucking fault for you!
I know you didn't.
He took the fault for you for like 30 minutes.
What is this guy talking about, bro?
I'm gonna go live too.
I just...
Wait, you weren't live?
You weren't live?
What happened?
My OBS reset.
I guess we got tired of listening to your stupid ass.
You guys sent a friend?
Yeah.
I think RPR is the lobby leader, so...
Yeah, no, you can even just join via like friends list.
Cause that's what I did.
Alright, let me add to...
Now I have like three Zeller accounts on here.
Yeah!
No problem!
The fact that he named all of them Zeller too.
Zeller, Zeller, Zeller.
Yeah, cold fuckers.
Cause they're all new accounts, bro.
He's the sus one.
Okay, I'm going live.
Alright, what do I do?
How do I join via friend list?
You just like go to the friends and then do join game.
Socials, this one.
Ah, friends.
You got this, buddy.
I have zero friends.
What the fuck, man?
What do you mean?
We all had it too.
How do I... Oh, this one.
Join squad.
Nice!
Let's go!
We're doing it!
Yeah!
Fucking hell.
Alright, my cam is... My cam is on and I'm not bald.
There we go.
We could be a wig.
Bro!
You could have got a wig.
Bro, bro.
Let's go to like...
Bro, you're open voice, bro.
You're open voice.
Are we not gonna use open voice?
Let's use open voice, it'll be funnier.
Bro, it's the same thing.
There's no proximity chat.
It'll be funnier.
No proximity chat.
I'm gonna get kicked out.
Well, that's your fucking problem, bro.
You're my problem, man.
You're my problem.
Well, sucks to be you, dickhead.
Helldivers doesn't even have proximity voice.
We can all hear each other regardless.
What?
Okay, that's shit.
Yeah!
How do we turn it off then?
How do we turn this shit off?
Options, is it?
Audio?
Voice chat?
This one.
Disabled.
Bro, guys.
RPR is a super citizen.
He actually paid for this.
He actually paid for this game more than it should be.
Look at this guy.
What the fuck?
He was like flexing his paid cosmetics to us.
Oh yeah, guess what?
I paid $200 for this fucking game.
Yeah, we're his paid cosmetics.
RPR, I'm a free player.
Can you buy for me too?
Yeah, can you buy for us?
Yeah, look at us.
Look at my army.
I'm just a baby.
I just spent $40 bucks for Zeller.
Like, how looks... like...
How do you guys do these emotes?
Did your clothes hurt?
It's B.
How do you guys do emotes and shit, bro?
You were in the tutorial.
What do you mean?
Uh, what tutorial?
I skipped it.
You were in two tutorials.
It's B.
Alright, let's go kill some bugs, guys.
I wanna shoot them up.
Let's do the robots.
Yeah.
No, we should... actually, no.
Let's not do the robots.
I feel like Zeller's gonna kill us.
Robots?
No, no, no.
There's no robots in this game.
There's no robots.
Bro, dude, dude, dude.
Trust me, yo.
Robots and... like me?
It's like a duo, yo.
Dynamite.
It's like... it's like sandwich and mayonnaise.
I'm the mayonnaise.
You're doing...
There's no one liberating this planet.
You're doing wonderful, buddy.
You're doing wonderful.
He's doing great.
I'm liberating right now.
Bro, bro, bro, bro.
Come back.
Got me up, homie.
Galactic wheelchair.
We got this.
What are we doing, RPR?
Which way?
Wait, my mic is wrong.
Here.
Thanks.
Yeah.
Where are we going, RPR?
Where are we going?
I didn't mean to hit you.
Who are we liberating?
Let's ult and win a new game.
My mic is way too dank.
We're going Erato Prime.
Dank?
Ooh.
We're going level nine?
Level nine?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Let's go, let's go, let's go, let's go.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Zeller's a fucking baby.
No, I'm not.
You're also a baby.
I am a preteen right now.
Excuse me?
Excuse you, I'm preteen.
Gosh, in my preteens, I was playing Neopets.
Oh shit!
Neopets Adventure Quest Club Penguin.
Club Penguin!
That shit was fire.
I was a waiter in the pizzeria.
Dude, the pizzeria.
They were like these little fucking fluff balls, remember?
Puffballs!
Yeah, whatever they're called.
I was ruining the dates at the pizzeria.
The fucking snowboarding shit.
Hey pizzeria, what did this kid play?
He can only do like baby level.
Remember the dojo card game that they had?
I remember the fucking sled races.
No, it was sled races and there was this dojo fucking card game you could play.
I forgot what it was called.
It's called, I don't know.
Karjutsu?
What's a karjutsu?
I don't know.
And then there was like, you can be like a secret agent too.
I was golden at the game bro.
Yeah.
Secret agent.
Dude, RPR is too old.
He doesn't know this kind of stuff.
Yeah, he is.
He doesn't relate to us.
He's not listening to you guys.
He used to play like fucking Tetris and shit, man.
I don't give a shit about games.
He was playing Second Life while we were playing Club Penguin.
He was a fucking Tetris guy.
Getting the fucking hell putt, bro, man.
Bro, I'm getting in.
Oh, I got this one.
I got the all the way to the top.
To the right side.
I'm trying to get us in the game and they're just flaming me.
What the fuck is this?
All right, we pick our gear.
Okay.
I'll take an autocannon.
All right, I only have three stratagems.
What the fuck?
I have offensive, supply.
Huh?
None of you...
I go with the supply then.
Fuck it.
I'll take a health pot.
Oh, wait.
I have two.
I'm readied.
Sounds good.
Okay.
Ready?
I don't know what...
It's all right.
RPR and Han can carry us.
They have the actual good stratagems.
No, come on.
We're a team.
I'm there for moral support.
Me too.
Zeller, Zeller, Zeller.
You don't want any of those red stratagems.
You don't want any of those red...
That's all he has.
That's the thing.
That's the problem.
I'm clipping.
You don't want...
How do I unclip it?
No, no, no.
Keep it, keep it, keep it.
It should be fine.
No, you're so fucking dead.
What do you mean?
Oh!
I'm so fucking dead.
Oh, I know what he means.
No, it's okay.
He doesn't even remember how to activate his stratagem.
No, I do.
It was like the code shit.
It was like the beep, beep, boop, beep.
That shit, right?
Exactly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just when you throw it, just at least let us know.
Okay.
Bro, if you didn't say that, now he's definitely not going to let us know.
What do you mean?
I'm a commander, yo.
Okay.
You're a cadet.
We're both cadets.
The lucky bird is not ready.
Let's go.
Wait, I did.
Oh, I am ready.
Let's go.
Let's kill some bugs.
Bro, you know, when I was like fucking seven or six years old, we were fucking blockbusters, right?
Uh-huh.
And my dad was like, hey, let's get this like movie thing.
It's really cool, you know?
And I was like, oh yeah, what is it?
You know, Starship Troopers, right?
That shit traumatized me when I was a fucking kid.
Dude, like, there was like this fucking...
We're doing our part.
There was like this guy.
Yeah.
There was this guy who was like in the plane, like, we're gonna go kill him.
And then he gets his fucking legs chopped off.
And I was like, I was like, what the fuck is this?
I went, I went to my dad's room, right?
When I was like super, super young.
He was watching Starship Troopers.
I had no idea what it was.
I walked in.
Someone's brain was getting sucked out by a monster.
What the fuck?
Okay, that part was not scary.
The brain sucky.
It was so scary.
What do you mean?
No, the brain sucky fucky was not that scary.
The brain sucky what?
All right, calling in my machine gun.
What's this?
What do we do with this?
What do you mean?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, shit.
Oh, shit.
What's going on?
What is this shooting?
Zeller, Zeller, come here.
Zeller, come here.
Come on.
Come here.
Right here.
Check it out.
Ready?
What are you doing?
What are you?
Oh, wait.
Who's who?
I'm D2.
Yo, this motherfucker killed me.
He's teabagging me.
I request reinforcement.
Okay, X4 is Zeller.
At least we know.
Now, I request reinforcement.
All the trouble you've given me.
Oh, shit.
I'm back, bitches.
That's for the two hundred.
Oh, my God.
That's for the two hundred dollars.
Two hundred dollars?
What you mean?
I paid two hundred dollars.
Okay, where's the...
Guys, Zeller landed on me and I died.
Oh,
fucking Zeller.
Zeller, Zeller.
You are in danger.
You're in front of me!
That's not my fault!
You walked in front of my bullet!
RPI help us!
RPI...
How did I land on you?
That's your fault for...
You landed on me!
I saved you!
Did you?
You killed me.
I also saved you, you can't deny that!
I'm not being good!
I got you!
Please don't get me anymore!
Please do not get me!
I got a reload apparently.
Oh yeah, don't like...
If you reload you lose your ammo in the reload.
So don't reload unless you have to.
Okay...
Where's my machine gun?
No!
I left the light.
You landed on Han and then you killed Rookie right now.
Oh, oh, oh.
What the fuck is that?
That's a METRONAUT!
What the fuck?!
This is not going very well.
No, I didn't!
Remember I wrote in chat, I was like, I think Xenon is going to kill us the most because he just finished the tutorial.
He hasn't!
Guys...
Alright, look, I'll just fucking go right up on the...
I'll just fucking... come on, if I'm not near you guys, I can't kill you.
I can't kill you guys, right?
Yeah, go off to the sunset.
I don't know that.
I got you, I got you.
I feel like you're gonna find a way.
You're gonna find a way.
These guys look like fucking crabs and shit.
Boy...
Bro, you gotta stop...
Bro, we gotta like...
Nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
We're so good.
Oh, big guy!
Bro, there's fall damage.
I forgot.
Shoot his butt, shoot his butt!
I'm shooting, I'm shooting the ass!
Beep, beep!
Shoot his leg.
I did something...
Ah, resupply here, guys!
Oh, I got you, I got you.
Oh my god, please do not throw this at us.
Please don't throw this at us.
Wait, is this guy dead?
Alright, we need ten more.
We need to kill ten more.
Wait, I think I remember this guy.
Isn't this guy the guy that comes out of the fucking dirt and like...
ate the girl in half or some shit?
Oh, this is like legally...
Oh, what?!
You shot me!
What do you mean?
I didn't shoot anybody!
See?
It's not me.
You shot me!
I don't know what you're talking about.
You have no proof.
You're not streaming.
You don't have proof.
Alright, guys, I got you.
Are you really going back on your shame?
Guys, I threw something.
I threw something.
Uh-oh.
It's fine.
We're fine.
What?!
You shot me!
I told you I threw it.
Get back!
I told you I threw something.
Okay, what do I do with this?
Hello, I'm coming back.
Oh, that's a free gun.
I don't know whose gun this is, but...
I'm here now.
Hey, guys, look at us.
We did the mission.
We did it.
Nice!
Let's go home, guys.
Wee!
Yay!
I was cooking, man.
Flawless.
Oh, I was fucking cooking.
Someone needs to flip that shit.
He lands on Han right next to me, picks up his autocannon, and shoots the shit in her ass right now.
What?
Huh?
Guys, we did our first mission.
I'm so happy.
I don't know what happened.
I'm so happy we picked the mission where we don't have to leave spawn.
Thank fucking God.
Thank God.
I'm not in this office with me, man.
Holy shit.
Okay, let's see who had the least deaths.
It doesn't show that.
No?
Yay!
Look at us!
We got five stars, guys!
Let's go!
We did so well.
We were cooking.
Holy shit.
I feel like Zeller did not deserve to level up.
I had the most experience point.
You know what that means.
We all get the same amount of experience.
We got the same experience.
It's just because you're level one.
Well, it's a thought that counts.
It looks like I got more.
Look at that default.
No, no, no, no.
I'm not default.
I'm clapping.
That's different.
Let's see.
Friendly fire damage 25.
Look at the stats right now.
The stats.
Okay, let's see the stats.
Doki died four times.
I wonder why.
Dude, I have more kills than Doki.
Oh, yeah.
I was dead like 80% of the fucking round.
No, that's just... that's a youth problem.
Sorry, guys.
Sorry, I tripped and fell.
Everything was in the air.
I didn't even use a stim, bro.
I didn't even use a heal, you know.
Sorry, guys.
I tripped and fell.
Accidents happen.
Friendly fire damage 25.
We are 40 minutes late to this first game.
Literally being a movie.
Someone needs to just make a clip of that entire first game from his POV.
Bro, 2583 friendly damage.
What the fuck?
You did more damage on your team than the fucking bugs.
Hell yeah.
I'm going... I'm fucking going in.
Bro, I was like pressing some random buttons.
Like, what's this?
And then I threw something.
I was like, what the fuck is that?
And then it like started going off.
I was like, that's a fucking grenade.
Guys, I threw something.
I threw something.
Everyone fucking dies.
Bro, I don't think... I don't think Zeller will... I don't think we should take Zeller to the robot island.
I don't think we should...
Dude, leave it to me, man.
Probably not a good idea.
There's no way.
There's no way we're going to survive robot land.
I'll cook.
Now you guys... Now chat can tell that like I was not the problem that we're like here.
Like, look what he's doing in game.
Like, you guys think he can handle steam?
Fuck you mean, man?
I had it already and then...
Dude, I count problems, okay?
I think RPR is a little low in volume.
RPR boost your volume.
Yeah, RPR boost...
Just talk louder in your office.
You can maneuver the pawn.
Talk louder, I'm gonna get kicked.
Talk louder.
All right, guys.
This time we're a team, right?
Yep, totally.
Ah, ah, me too.
Yeah, we killed.
Yeah, totally.
Watch your back, Zeller.
Watch your back.
I'll kill you guys.
Don't you worry.
Am I louder?
Hello?
Oh, I'm in the autocannon.
Okay, can you guys hear me?
Yeah, we can hear you.
What the fuck is that?
Wait, what are you guys all throwing?
Oh, we're throwing machine guns.
Oh, it's the supply.
Yeah.
What happened?
Hey, guys, I'm dead.
They have supplies.
What the fuck just happened?
Boo-hoo!
Boo -hoo!
Yeah, surprise.
All back, bitches!
Why not?
Look, that was not my fault you were a casualty.
What do you mean it wasn't your fault?
You should have known what that was!
I got a free machine gun!
I was minding my own business!
Somehow I only got team kill points.
Where's my machine gun?
I lost it!
I died!
You didn't take my machine gun!
Oh, I did.
Thank you.
Did someone take my auto backpack?
Oh, I did.
I have everything.
You're gonna have to reload me later.
What?
How do I reload you?
Okay, here, take this.
Take the machine gun!
I got you, machine gun!
Where's my machine gun?
It's coming!
I'm gonna do the objective.
Oh, yes, nice!
My machine gun!
I gotta reload, guys.
I'm reloading.
I couldn't get my machine gun!
I couldn't get it!
I need to come back.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Are you dead again?
Wow.
You're pretty shit at this game, Ghosty.
Oh, yeah!
Where the fuck's my machine gun, Zeller?
Because he died twice, I guess I have to take it in my own hands.
RPR, I got your six.
Oh, I found it.
There you go, I got it.
Don't worry, we're helping now.
It's so fucking sandy, man.
RPR, raise your volume, you're still low.
I got you guys, I got the machine gun!
Wonderful.
And he's dead.
Yeah, I think he's dead, guys.
I think I get my ammo back at least.
Yay!
I think he's dead, guys.
I can't see shit, there's a sandstorm!
It's a little rough.
This is a little rough.
Who chose this game?
Coming!
Welcome back!
I can't see anything.
Where do we go?
Uh, let's go...
Guys, I have the ultimate weapon.
What is it?
I swear to God, if you're gonna throw this...
It's the orbital weapon, I got it.
RPR's standing still, Zeller.
I'm fixing my audio, is it better now?
Oh yeah, that's a lot better, actually.
I got the ultimate, I got my ultimate with me, guys.
What the fuck is your ultimate?
Throw it.
Huh?
Okay.
You want me to throw the ultimate?
Yeah, throw it.
Don't be a little bitch, throw it.
No no no, don't do that, don't do that, don't do that.
We don't need that.
Huh?
Throw it.
There they are, I threw it, I threw it, I threw it!
It's coming!
Yes, the orbital strike!
Two, one!
What?
Boom!
There we go, look at him, he's learning!
Wow.
He's actually learning!
They already all died, though.
You guys killed a lot of dead bodies.
Dude, you guys made...
You guys did not make my ultimate worth, you guys wasted it.
What do you mean you did that?
You guys didn't need to kill all of them.
No no no, that was all you, that was your bomb.
It was all you.
I'm gonna bomb you guys.
What did we do?
We literally picked you up!
You killed them all!
You killed them all, what do we do?
Oh no, I'm reloading.
Dude, I have to stop reloading, man.
I'm giving you moral support.
Oh, you gotta stop reloading this gun.
Wait, RPR, what do we do, RPR?
I don't know this objective, you're the super citizen.
I'm signal strengthening.
Are you doing the puzzle?
I can't see it, because you guys are sitting here.
Thanks guys, thank you, that really helped.
You're the super citizen, RPR, you should be able to know what to do.
Yeah, yeah, that really helped, guys, thanks, thanks.
No problem.
I'm glad we're helpful, guys.
Alright, um...
Wait, do you guys wanna like do everything, or do the main objective only?
Wait, we should teach Zeller how to play this, so we should do everything.
Uh oh.
Okay, come with me then.
Whoa!
You fucking...
What happened?
How is, how are you guys dead all the time?
We let Zeller cook.
Zeller cooked a little bit too long, let's just say.
I'm back!
Wait, how did you do that?
How did you do that?
F, F, F, F, F, F.
No, where's my machine gun?
He's coming back.
No, what the fuck!
Why was it always me?
Why is it always me?
We literally kicked his ass.
What the fuck.
We could have failed this mission or...
actually failed this mission.
Well then okay.
I'm gonna steal somebody's gun.
Oh, this is my railgun now.
AAH!
Eh, mine.
These small crabs!
Where's my... that railgun?
What the fuck?
Holy shit!
Something help me!
No, please!
We're fine, we're fine.
No, no, no, no, no!
He's dead, bro.
It's okay, we can call him back!
It's okay, it's ugly!
I don't have a railgun.
I got you, I got you, I got you.
Zeller is so lucky that this is unlimited reinforcements.
No, it's not, we have nine reinforcements.
No, no, it's unlimited!
What are you guys talking about?
It's unlimited.
I got the grenade, I got the grenade!
Leave it to me!
No, no, no, no, no!
BOOM!
Who keeps giving him grenades?
Nice, nice, I killed him, I killed him, I killed him, I killed him.
No, you didn't, there's still bugs in front of us.
What do you mean?
Well, not all of them, I didn't say all of them.
Okay, I killed one.
I'm so proud of you.
I made the game look like Roblox.
The one out of a hundred bugs in this island, in this planet.
Oh my gosh.
Oh no!
Guys, we have dead teammates.
I stood in front of RPR's ray gun.
We're good, we're good, we're good, we're good.
Nice.
That's where you died?
Yeah, I stood in front of the ray gun.
Oh, acid!
He spat acid on me, man.
Oh no, where's the rail gun that's still from RPR?
Wait, don't you smell the rail gun?
Bring it back.
What did I do?
I'm back.
You're stealing my rail gun.
Wait, wait, yeah, I want good weapons too.
Where's the good weapon?
Give us the good weapon.
Wait, it doesn't even have ammo.
What are you doing?
Sample container.
I got the sample container.
No!
Nice.
You wanted me, I'm gonna kill you.
Fuck you!
What's that?
Oh!
What's this?
Oh, I got something cool, yo.
You should've not murdered me, man.
Bro!
Bring us back!
Cool!
It's cool.
It's okay, we have unlimited.
Oh, I got the rail gun, guys.
I got the rail gun.
It's okay, guys.
We have unlimited.
If you drop my fucking gun.
There's no...
Oh!
I'm gonna die.
Maybe we should just do the regular objectives, because I don't think we can do the extra ones.
No, we can do it.
I couldn't even...
We're gamers.
You literally played 10 hours of Helldivers 2 yesterday.
Are you trying to say you can't do it?
Are you trying to say you're not a gamer, hun?
Is that it?
I knew you said I won.
Wait, I think I'm OP at this game.
Oh, shit.
Something's hitting me.
Uh-oh.
Wait, where do we go?
RPR, where do we go?
You're supposed to tell us where to go.
We're going to the main mission, because there's just no way we're gonna do anything else.
Ooh, a rail gun.
Ooh.
Yeah, you're not getting the rail gun.
What do you mean?
Okay.
Eventually...
Especially not one, though.
I got one, though.
Eventually, we're gonna get it.
I'm scared of...
What if...
Okay, no.
How do you use the railgun?
You just... you shoot it like any other gun, Zeller.
What do you mean?
You have to reload it after you shoot a bullet.
He's doing great.
So you shoot a bullet, press R.
Shoot a bullet, press R.
Oh!
Let's do this.
Who wants to be my teammate?
My stamina is so low.
I can't run anymore.
What is this?
Wow.
What?
Oh!
Ouch!
Bro, you guys are like bullying babies.
That's fucked up.
Watch out!
Nice.
Good luck, guys.
I'll be reloading my ammo.
Oh, hey.
There's more grenades here.
So with railgun, you shoot this guy's legs, not his ass.
Zeller, you can reload the grenades here.
Oh, grenade?
No, I have four grenades.
There's grenades in the fucking area.
I have four.
I have a lot of grenades.
Wonderful.
That's what he needs.
More grenades.
There you go.
Nice!
So you shoot his leg twice with railgun and then you can...
It breaks the armor and then you just shoot the leg until he dies.
How come Zeller gets to have a railgun and I can't?
You can have a railgun.
Here.
Can I...
There you go.
Yay!
I got fed!
Also, I'll just... I mean, I'll have you both know you both stole that railgun from me and the roler duck and you will die eventually when I have enough.
A rubber duck?
I want a rubber duck.
You want a... You want some ammo, Hattie?
Like, we can make some ammo real quick here.
Wait, we're getting glam?
I'm so down.
I'm so happy I have a railgun now.
Yay!
Yippee!
Is that a railgun even?
What's this?
Explosive barrel.
Oh my god.
Oh no, do not shoot it.
No, I got it.
I got it.
Can I shoot it?
I got it, yo.
No!
Hey, uh, we don't need to reinforce him, do we?
Wait, I can steal his railgun.
Where's his railgun?
True!
You already took his railgun.
How many times do you want to take it?
As many times as you want.
As many times as I can.
This is called bullying.
We have two reinforcements.
It's not bullying if I'm also a baby.
We have two reinforcements and then...
Oh, you tried, didn't you?
What?
Try what?
What do you mean try?
Try your best.
That's what you're doing.
Hell yeah, you know it.
You know what she did.
What are you guys talking about?
You didn't do anything.
You survived.
Here, Zeller, take this, okay?
Wait, I'm cooking.
I'm cooking.
You can have this autocannon.
Look, Zeller, look, look, look.
I'm going to throw a nuclear bomb.
Look, look, look.
Huh?
What are you going to do?
Uh-oh.
What's that eagle?
Oh, wow.
Whoa!
It's all right.
We can have a little radiation.
So what's so special about that?
That's pretty cool, right?
It's a nuclear bomb.
Oh.
Any more?
It's 500 kg.
Let's order more.
I can.
It's cool down.
Thank you.
Wait, you can technically have, like, unlimited nuclear bombs.
What's this?
Interact.
What are you doing, huh?
Oh, we have to escort this, guys.
Why are you so slow?
Oh!
Why are you so...
No!
He's not real.
No, no, no.
We are escorting him.
We're professionals.
It's fine.
We're fine.
I broke him.
Nice!
I forgot there's fall damage again.
Nice.
He's not a real human being.
Let me cook.
Yeah, I'm cooking.
Okay.
Sorry.
I stint.
Go click those buttons, guys.
We need more civilians.
Civilians!
What do we press?
What do we do, Artier?
I love killing civilians.
It's okay.
Don't kill civilians.
They're not real people anyway.
Yeah.
What about a leg shot?
Hey, how about a head shot for you?
What if they rail gun you?
No!
I have done nothing!
Why don't we just slap him?
We should slap him.
Yeah, let's bully him.
I am innocent.
He can just heal up.
We have unlimited reinforcements, remember?
Are you running?
Are you trying to run away from us?
I just see him try to serpentine.
I'm like, what?
He's like running in an S formation.
Bro, you have no stamina, bro!
Bugs!
Bro, you have no stamina!
Wow!
It's okay.
We're fine.
Bugs are good.
See?
Good job.
We're doing it.
All right.
Easy, easy, easy, easy.
So easy.
How many civilians are there?
Why are they all trapped?
I wasn't late.
Bro, now chat's lying to... bro, fuck all of you.
What did I do?
It's fine.
We didn't be late.
I wasn't late.
Bro, why were you late, RPR?
None of us were late, okay?
It was just technical issues.
Oh, yeah.
So now that...
Your brain was freaking late.
That works great for you, Zeller.
Yeah, none of us were late.
You're a bold man.
I'm a bold man.
L plus ratio.
Damn.
Where did you get that wig, RPR?
It's pretty nice.
Yeah, it's a pretty nice wig.
I'm not the bold one.
Manda's the bold one.
Let's go.
Where do we go now?
Where do we go?
RPR, super citizen.
Come to me.
Okay.
All right.
Where are you?
Dang, these turrets are broken.
Yeah, don't stand in front of it.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no.
What the fuck?
What?
What did you do?
Why did you do that?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
What did you do that?
I did nothing.
Why did you do that?
Wait, I broke my neck because you passed me in the air.
Bro, did you see how far I flew?
Holy shit, man.
I flew.
Bro, where are you?
By the way, the next person who dies can't come back for two minutes.
So use that information as you will.
Use that information as you will.
Let's go extract.
There's a giant bug following us from behind.
Not anymore.
He's still there.
What do you mean?
He's dead.
Nice.
Let's extract because we have no lives.
Wait.
Wait for us.
Me too.
Hey, baby girl.
Show Doki.
I saw it.
You dropped me like your friend.
Hey, what's up, baby girl?
I found one of these.
Oh, God.
I'll run into the monsters with this.
I will be the sacrifice.
We believe in you.
Just let me.
We have no lives.
No, we do.
We have one more.
He can use this for the last life.
But I can't run.
There's a bug behind.
We'll do this.
Me, guys.
Me.
What are you doing?
No sacrifice.
This is not fair.
Zeller, thank you for sacrificing yourself for the con.
Yeah, for like one cockroach.
Hey, a bug's a bug.
Zeller, a bug's a bug.
I can't believe it.
This is a scam.
Two seconds.
This is what you wanted, though.
Thank you for your sacrifice.
Thank you for it.
You did your part, Zeller.
You did your part.
You're a great asset to the company.
This is a scam.
I think the worst part was that bug didn't even die.
But guess what?
I am back.
Hey, welcome back.
Join the fray.
Let's go.
Onwards.
Oh, they are.
Wait, where is the extraction?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Don't worry.
Hell yeah, leave it to Mr. Zeller, bitch.
Uh-huh.
There's an orbital strike.
Oh, there's rockets here.
Oh, wait, there's rockets here.
Alright, there's an orbital walking barrage in one second.
Onwards.
You guys can pick up rockets.
You stuck him with that and he saw me.
No.
Bro, you're lying.
Why are you panicking?
Why are you so scared?
You're lying.
Look at me, cook.
Don't hit him.
Go.
I dropped the orbital thingy.
I'm so proud of you.
Oh my god, he's learning.
Wait, there's a floating rock.
There's rocket launchers here, guys.
Why are you holding them?
Oh, I got one.
It's okay, guys.
I'll know how to use it.
Rocket launcher?
Nice!
We did it!
We got them!
We got the nest!
Wait, why is there a floating rocket launcher here?
You can take it.
Hell yeah!
There's only like one shot though, isn't it?
Yeah, one shot's enough.
Who are you gonna shoot?
Who are you gonna shoot, Stellar?
A tank.
It says anti-tank.
Guys, I don't want to bunch up together right now.
I'm gonna jump next to you guys.
Where's the big guy?
Come on, show me the big one.
It's dead.
He's dead.
We did it.
I'm resupplying.
You're gonna respawn?
Resupply.
Oh yeah, I was gonna say, we can...
You know, we have one more if you want to respawn.
No, that's for Zeller.
I don't like how Zeller's walking around with it.
Me too.
I'm not bunching up with you guys.
I haven't killed anyone today yet.
What are these shiny...
He hasn't done it yet.
We killed him seven times in the first mission.
Dude, there's like...
shiny fruits over here.
Pick it up.
No, I'm just running.
I gotta get to the shuttle.
Don't worry, you have two minutes.
Zeller, we have two minutes.
Okay, okay.
Don't worry, we can do it.
You're gonna get to use your rocket launcher now.
Hell yeah.
Yeah, this is it.
This is the time.
I really want to shoot you right now, but I'm not going to.
How do I put this down?
Okay, like that.
Yeah.
Oh, there's a railgun!
Rocket launcher time!
Look, I'm feeding the kids by throwing their shoulder shots.
Oh my god, look at the railgun!
Wait, the sentry gun's killing everything.
I don't even have an opportunity to use it.
I'm gonna nuclear bomb that side.
Wait, which side?
Oh, I'm hiding, I'm hiding.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I am going to send in a cluster bomb right here.
They're here!
My...
You didn't even kill him.
No...
He killed me!
I did too!
Oh no!
Oh...
My...
Wait, did we...
Gosh... I'm in.
I'm in.
It's up to you!
Shoot bomb from extraction!
I'm running, I'm running, I'm running!
Oh, he's just...
I will save everybody!
We have 1 minute and 38 seconds!
You better!
RPR, why did you throw, RPR?
I didn't.
I pulled in a mortar, but you guys stood next to me.
You guys stood next to me.
Animals, so you exploded.
We all died, bro!
I was holding onto the gasoline tank and walking to the big dude.
Okay, listen, it's not my fault.
I can't believe RPR threw that.
I can't believe.
Clutch or kick.
Yeah, clutch or kick, Han.
Oh, bro, this seems like a nightmare.
Bro, I can't even fucking spectate him.
Holy sh...
I'm like looking at my own dead body.
Oh, okay, look at that movement!
Shit!
Are you kidding me?
Oh, no!
There's two of them.
He's fine, he's fine.
Shuttle's landing!
Live for 45 seconds so you can slowly bring each of us back.
You're so greedy.
It's gonna deduct points.
You don't want the points to be deducted.
Han, you don't want the points to be deducted.
You just have to live for like six more minutes.
Yeah, just live for six more minutes.
It's so easy.
It'll be so easy.
We're smelting.
Why is he still living?
Just four minutes.
How are you spectating it?
I'm just looking at my own dead body.
Me too.
What?
I don't know.
I'm spectating it somehow.
That's okay.
No!
Wait!
Are you dead?
Did you just leave?
No, he died.
Wait, you died?
I have no idea how I died there.
I was so far behind my thing.
Han Solo.
Bro, I guess we gotta kick him.
He didn't clutch.
To be honest, like, Zeller kinda spent like 18 of our...
Yeah, I didn't do nothing.
Worth while sacrifice.
Let's see the stats.
Let the stats talk for themselves.
I don't think he want us to look at the stats.
You guys do realize he loves Discord, right?
I leveled up.
You guys hear me?
Yeah, we can.
Oh wait, wait!
What happened to Han?
He'll come back.
You guys should watch your kick.
He kicked himself.
He's just taking a shit.
He actually kicked himself.
He couldn't clutch.
It's an excuse for him to go take shit.
Let's look at stats.
Let's see Zeller's stats.
Han did 4.1 kills initially.
Wait, Han did 4.000?
Bro, Han did 4.000?
Zeller did 10 times.
Look at my accuracy.
Bro!
Yes, because I was...
I had like the...
I had the unfortunate circumstances of being next to Zeller.
So that I got killed as well because I was right next to him.
Well, that's your fault.
Wrong place, wrong time.
Dumbass bitch.
That's your fault.
Not mine.
Mine.
How is that my fault?
You're right.
I should never stand next to you.
I'm never standing next to you again.
Now I can kill her and she won't know it's me because I'm far away.
What the fuck do you mean?
You're gonna kill like Han and RPR if I stand next to them.
Well, I guess that's that then.
Holy shit!
How the fuck did Han do 4.000 friendly fire?
How?
I think he killed Zeller like 15 times.
I only died 10 times, man!
It says here I only died 10 times.
Han actually kicked himself out of the group too.
Han, welcome back.
Han, you did 4.000 friendly fire damage, Han.
What the fuck?
He was so crazy.
It was fine.
Oh my god.
Wait, we unlocked hard difficulty, guys.
I'm on hard now.
Oh, yay.
Hard.
Guys, I think we can do hard difficulty.
I think we can do it.
It's not gonna go great, guys.
No, I think we can do it.
We should show Zeller the robot land.
Yeah, robot!
Let's go!
He wants to see the robots.
If we're going on hard mode, then we probably need like a super special team name, right?
What's your team name?
What's it gonna mean?
Yeah, the hard...
Yeah, RPR, finish that sentence.
What did he say?
Did he say you're getting hard?
What?
I'm just... I have no idea what he was talking about.
Wait, aren't you on Twitch so that people can clip that exact moment of what you just said?
You can clip on YouTube, too.
Alright.
Oh, it's the creek!
It's time for the creek!
The creek!
Here, let's try robots.
Are we doing the robots?
Yeah.
Right?
We're doing the creek, right?
Is this the creek?
Oh, is it the creek?
No, this is...
Why not the creek?
Are you a coward?
Where's the creek?
Team what?
Where is the creek?
I don't know.
I'm not the super citizen.
You don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
That's what's going on.
Let's go to the creek!
Wait, you lost the creek?
We lost?
We lost it.
Oh my god!
Yeah, we lost the fucking creek.
I can't believe it.
It's your fault, chat.
You didn't do it for liberty.
Poor chat.
I can't believe it, chat.
How could you guys do that?
What happened to liberty and democracy?
Honestly, it is Pat's fault.
I don't even know what it means.
What is this red line?
I don't know.
Take us there.
We can pick where we go.
No, wait.
That's a visual bug on my side.
Not you.
I can't believe it.
How do I get strong weapons as well, man?
You have to spend money to have the strong weapons.
Ah, fuck that shit.
No, you don't.
It's all in-game.
You unlock it from the ship.
I already spent $200 on this fucking game.
It's not paid to win.
I spent $40 for you.
I'm gonna shell fucking dinner for you.
Bro, you could have won that money.
You could have won that money.
Whatever.
You're buying everyone dinner, right?
Yeah, even me, right?
Who do you guys think you are?
RPR.
Doki?
Yeah.
Wait, why the fuck am I on a fucking- Ah!
Welcome to the robot land.
Bro, I just got both- Wait, robots?
Yeah, there's robots.
Oh, railgun!
Railgun.
You're not getting the railgun.
Oh shit, perfect!
I'm gonna get my machine gun.
I killed him.
I should have gotten the autocam.
Oh my god, you just died.
Are you crazy?
I threw the needle.
Holy shit.
Wait, this is one of the other movies, right?
What, Terminator?
Terminator?
Yeah, they have these robot-looking, Terminator-looking guys.
Yeah.
Alright, let's go to my ping, guys.
It's Y2K.
Hey.
Let's go.
Woo.
I really wanna shoot him.
Do it.
I mean, you can shoot him in the leg, I guess.
No!
Okay, sure, I'll shoot him in the leg.
Do it.
He's literally right there.
Wow!
I shot him with the leg.
Bro, that was my massive run.
Holy fuck.
Bro!
That was his chest.
I shot him in the leg.
Just with like a .50 caliber.
Yeah, those bullets definitely went further beyond the leg right there.
Uh-oh.
I'll kill you all!
Holy shit, you guys are popping off.
Holy shit.
Hey, come here.
Press E on this with me.
Alright.
What is this?
It's a bunker.
Oh, there's grenades.
Wee!
Open up!
Uh...
Wow, there's some cool loot in here.
I'll take it.
Thank you.
Alright, see you guys later.
This is my stream now.
What was she doing?
She clutched your kick.
Another diamond!
Woo!
What were you thinking?
What do you think was gonna happen?
Well...
The problem was that I wasn't really thinking.
I can't believe you've done this.
Solo season 2.
I'm solo.
Oh my god!
Wait, I realized I can play that now.
I can play on this.
Open up!
Oh shit!
They got blind!
Watch out.
I'm watching.
Uh...
I mean, I did warn him.
Yeah, I don't think he watched out.
Not me specifically.
He said he was watching.
Yeah, we did watch.
Yeah.
Who's reinforcing him?
I killed like 10 of them though.
At least you're watching, you know.
Yeah.
Did he actually kill 10 of them?
I don't think he did.
I did!
Alright, we got it.
Oh wait, it's puzzle time!
It's puzzle time!
Do the puzzle!
Do the thing!
Go for it.
You've got massive brain of yours.
No, you have to spin the radar dish.
Wait, oh yeah.
Wait, we can spin it now?
No, no we can't.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, don't worry.
I can spin it.
I know.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh shit, there's big...
There's big robots!
I can kill those.
Do you spin it from over here?
No, you spin it here where I am right now.
Oh, I can spin it!
Okay, how do you do this?
Am I spinning it?
I'll let you know.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Am I doing it?
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Stop, stop, stop.
I give you a countdown for a reason!
We did it!
How do I get off?
Okay, I got it.
Yay!
Where are we going?
We gotta destroy the ships right here.
Okay.
Alright, leave it to me.
Leave it to us.
It's a team game.
Hey, that looks like a grenade you just threw.
Wait, I got it.
I know what to do.
It's a nuclear bomb I just threw.
I threw a cluster bomb.
Run, run, run, run!
Oh my god, are you crazy?
What do you mean?
What does that do?
Look, see?
Wow.
Look at that, it was beautiful.
It's like fireworks.
I think it's cooler than RPRs.
What do you mean?
I dropped a nuke.
There was more explosions though.
Yeah, but mine was like big.
Yeah, see?
It killed everything.
Nice.
This is so easy.
Look at us.
We're working together.
Oh, behind me, behind me, behind me!
Good luck.
Behind him, guys.
Ah, shit!
Guys!
Guys, why are we all split up?
Wait, how did I die?
Help us!
Guys, the baby needs help.
The baby needs help.
Let's kill them all now.
We're back.
I got you, I got you.
See, look at us, working together.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, this guy got flamethrowers and shit.
I'm fucking blasting.
It's a Hulk, it's a Hulk.
Wait, this guy ain't taking damage.
It's okay, I'm throwing a nade.
I'm throwing a nade.
Your nades aren't reliable.
What do you mean?
I just really don't think the Hulk.
I'm throwing another nade.
Oh, behind us.
Oh, no.
I'm stimming.
Oh my god, it's AT&T.
AT&T?
I got you, I got you, I got you, I got you.
Maybe I don't, but I kinda got you.
No!
Guys, I don't think he got you.
Dude, there were five of them behind you, bro.
What am I meant to do against five dudes?
Like, wave my hand at them?
You had me, man.
Come on.
Yeah, you had him.
You could've done it.
No, I didn't have him.
Why did you say you had him?
Were you lying?
Maybe she can handle five guys, but I can't handle five guys.
Okay?
There's a difference.
Ooh, auto-channeled backslash.
Wait, what's your limit for?
I would run away.
Run away.
Why are we running, yo?
Why are we running?
Whoa, shit!
We did it, we did it, we did it!
Whoa!
What was that, man?
Wait, who are we missing?
Who are we missing right now?
I don't know.
Who did you guys kill earlier?
Oh, shit!
It's mine!
Hey guys, can you bring me back?
Wait, Zeller, if you come here, look at this red shit.
No!
I step on it and I die, right?
I'm not that dumb.
No, no, that's loot.
That's loot.
Dude, there's a tank!
I gotta do this for us.
Yeah, that's...
Holy cow, that shit's real!
I think I destroyed it.
I threw nades at it.
I destroyed the tank!
Run!
Oh my god, what is going on?
Don't worry, I'm here now.
Oh, that's a tank, that's a tank, that's a tank.
I got my auto-nade.
I got it, I got it, I got it.
No, the nades don't work!
I have a strike, I have a strike, I have a strike!
Okay, okay, okay.
I have a strike, it's going down!
I have a strike too!
Throw everything, throw everything at the tank.
Let's do it, let's do it!
We got this!
We did it, Zeller!
Zeller, we did it!
We went to mine!
The fucking mine!
I stepped on a mine!
No!
Guys, there's a tank.
I stepped on a fucking mine!
I got one of the tanks!
I did my job.
I saw the tanks blow up, I got so happy, ran back and stepped on a fucking mine!
Yeah, you can shoot the mine.
Yes, that's what I'm doing!
We can just walk around it.
No more mines.
Just don't walk into the red thing.
Yeah, you know, normal people would just not die to it.
Yeah, yeah, what are you trying to do?
What are you trying to do, Zeller?
What are you trying to do?
We're built different.
Let's walk this way, guys.
Wait, Zeller has the Uber Eats!
Huh?
Uber Eats what?
Look at him!
He has the Uber Eats!
I'll ring the doorbell and be like, hey, yo, what's up, baby girl?
Let me get your Instagram.
Is this what you think happens for Uber Eats?
Look at him!
All the Uber Eats that I've ordered, they've been really nice to me.
I've never had an asshole, except one who didn't come and ate the food.
So, like, your Uber Eats people, like, go up to you and ask for your Instagram?
No, they don't!
Oh, what's that?
Oh, my eyesight's blurry.
I can't see anything.
Return back to combat!
Traitor detected!
Did we all die?
Killed by Zellers.
By Zellers?
Zellers?
I said I died by Zellers!
By Zellers?
Look, I'm killing everyone, okay?
Yes, including us, apparently.
No, they're flying!
I got you, I got you, I got you.
I got you, guys.
I got you.
Bro, he's gonna fucking die.
Bro, I need to know Zellers team damage.
I need to know.
You leave the combat zone.
The ship's above us.
They're gonna start shooting missiles at you.
So then, I'm guessing that...
I'm guessing that Zellers...
I was right in front of them, bro.
What the fuck?
Why is my vision blurry?
You literally said that to us.
What do you mean?
What?
No, um...
I'm aging, you know?
Just follow me, man.
How did I also age?
We didn't fucking get bombed!
Huh?
Aging, not Asian!
I thought he said...
Oh my god.
Everyone accepts RPR is gonna be blurry.
But then RPR is like...
RPR is like aging aging.
So he'll be blurry too.
So in the end, we'll all be...
Uninstall the stream.
Run back!
There's a bomb!
Where do we go?
Oh shit!
There was a nuclear bomb.
Why didn't anyone talk about it?
Because I threw it away from you guys.
So you guys can't die.
Oh, that's so sweet.
Oh, Terminator boys!
It's okay, we're fine.
We just better... Watch out behind!
There's so many!
And here we go!
I have no ammo!
I'm dead guys.
No!
I'm running!
I only have a grenade!
I'm going grenade!
I missed.
Spawn us in, please.
What do you mean?
We're doing so well!
Check inside!
Okay, yeah, yeah.
I'm checking.
What was that?
My chest is bleeding!
I have a stim.
There's a guy with a big shield.
We need to kill him.
That guy is strong.
I got you.
Don't go anywhere near that.
I got you too.
I got you.
Run, run, run, run!
I think I got him.
I got you.
I just shot him.
He's still alive.
I see him.
Don't go near that.
Don't go near what?
No, go, go.
He's dead.
You're a horrible person.
He is dead.
What do you mean?
I'll never die.
He was dead.
I was telling the truth.
Oh, shit, guys!
Okay, I'm going to get another machine gun.
I got you.
I'm on fire.
What the fuck?
Oh, shit.
There's more.
I only have a pistol.
Zellar, get away from me!
I'm staying near you so you get the fucking...
My machine gun is literally coming down.
Yay.
You guys are doing great.
You're doing great, guys.
We're doing it.
We have like four left.
Okay, I got another machine gun.
Objective.
We got to go to objective.
I got an orbital strike.
Orbital strike coming.
ATT!
No, no, no, no.
Return to tactical zone.
No, we have to return.
Oh, no!
I'm getting hit.
I'm good.
No bullets.
I have no... I need more bullets.
I need more bullets.
Why are you shooting me?
I'm shooting behind you.
Okay, I'm going to get...
Where's... Where's RPI?
We need to get to RPI.
I'm leaving you guys, bro.
I'm leaving you guys.
Machine gun.
20 seconds, guys, okay?
I'm running towards him.
I'm going to get to you guys.
You're running from the supplies.
I'm running.
Over here.
I don't need ammo.
We don't need ammo.
We're so good.
I want my life.
We have resupply.
We don't need bullets.
Okay.
I have my machine...
My heavy machine gun.
He just wants to give you guys some ammo.
They were like, oh, I don't have any bullets.
I don't have any bullets.
I wanted to give them bullets.
I have machine gun now.
And I have grenades.
Okay.
We got this.
Just believe in us.
Here's the thing.
If we run away, we don't need ammo.
I'm not going to lie.
I gave up when you guys went away.
I just started running away.
You're a horrible person.
How could you?
You should revoke your super citizen.
You're not a super citizen.
You don't help others.
Because instead of...
Yeah?
Go.
Instead of what?
One second.
I was throwing a nuclear bomb.
Instead of fucking around with you guys, I'm liberating.
We're liberating too.
You're liberating your brain cells.
What do you mean?
We're liberating.
We're doing our part.
I'm doing my part.
I'm doing my part too.
Being happy.
We're here now.
See?
We're here.
Thanks for coming guys.
That's right.
That was not me.
Just so you know.
I got you.
Nice.
Oh, mine.
Land mine.
I got you.
No, I'm already dead.
The land mine got me already.
Oh shit.
I'm burning.
Someone get me too.
Okay, when you start burning, just heal.
And it will heal the blood.
Why can't I stop drop and roll?
That's not how it works in this world.
What?
So it was all alive?
I got the machine gun.
It works on Earth.
Just not on the fuck where we are.
Different atmosphere.
Okay, we're fine.
I'm throwing a nade.
Oh, there's a big guy.
Big guy.
Oh, hey.
Let me...
He's fine.
I said I'm throwing a nade.
I said...
What are you throwing?
Look at his loot.
I'm taking his loot.
I'm taking his loot too.
Oh, railgun.
Oh, fuck.
I didn't count.
Oh, you thought you had it.
You thought you could.
You thought you could kill us.
Bro, I look like...
Bro, you ran into my nade.
And then you guys just robbed me.
What do you want me to do?
It's called putting into a trust fund when you die.
I need more bullets.
Oh man, if only you went to the supply thing that I gave you.
Yeah, if only you went there.
Look, I was saving you.
Mine.
I stepped on it, but it didn't go off.
Look at us.
We're doing great.
I think we're doing pretty well.
Resupply.
I got the resupply too.
We don't need them.
Yes, we do.
I'm going to objective.
Where's the objective?
Right in front of us.
Okay, what do we have to do?
We have to destroy AirBase control tower.
This is one of the harder ones.
This is going to be fun.
What difficulty are we on?
Hard mode right now.
Oh, this is hard?
It's so easy.
It's easy, I know.
It was so easy.
If you guys didn't team kill each other, it would be a lot easier.
See, you killed yourself.
You killed yourself.
I got burned to death because I'm too busy talking to you dumbass.
Why did you heal?
We can turn it down on difficulty if you want.
Why did you heal, RPR?
What happened to healing?
We're cool with hard difficulty.
Yeah, apparently.
He died like two times in a row.
You guys are not real.
Don't go near that.
Woah, woah, woah.
I'm going to run away.
Look at this, there's a turret gun.
I'm on a turret gun.
Holy shit.
Wow, get everybody that's behind us.
Alright, we're here.
I'm here.
There's no one behind us.
I'm doing my part.
Yeah, you guys are fighting ghosts behind us while I'm liberating this tower.
You don't know what's in front of you.
Woah, there's actual people in front of us.
Woah, woah, woah.
I just did rocket launcher.
RPR, you died again.
I got you, I got you.
I got rocket launcher.
What just killed me?
How did we go over there, Doki?
Right here.
Let me watch the real content.
Oh my god, he fell off.
Wait, how do I...
Okay, reload.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to figure out how to use this really good.
Easy money, easy money.
Cash money.
Oh, you shot me.
No, I shot the robot.
I shot the robot.
No, no, I did.
I shot a robot.
He's dead.
I did my part.
How much?
44 seconds?
RPR, you need to stop dying.
We don't have enough trees to die.
You guys say that 15 times.
Look at us.
RPRC, we're cooking.
I'm grenade-ing.
That's not a good grenade.
You're gonna kill us.
What the fuck do you mean?
You nearly killed us on solo out here.
I'm doing my best.
Greeter shot first, and Greeter is Doki.
I mean, you didn't die.
You ran away.
Wow!
Oh my god, oh my god.
I got shot by your fucking...
I got shot by a fucking robot drone.
Nice.
Turret, turret, turret.
Use the turret.
Where are they?
I got it.
I don't know how to use it correctly.
I don't know if there's any on this side.
There is.
I got one guy.
Nice.
Oh my god.
They're fucking falling from the skies.
Where are they?
It's okay, guys.
I'm killing everybody on my side.
I'm not encountering anyone.
Why is that?
It's okay.
I did it.
I killed like 20.
Oh man.
Welcome back.
I'll do the mission, guys.
Don't worry.
You guys keep killing.
I put the hard drive in.
I don't know where I am or who I am, but I know I'm here to kill.
I'm gonna follow you.
You know what to do.
Where are you?
We're just waiting.
Oh, Zeller, do the thing.
I believe in you.
He did it!
Good job, bro.
Good job, Zeller.
See?
Leave it to me, man.
Leave it to me.
Zeller is important to this team.
Okay, let's do this.
Are we doing it?
Oh yeah, now...
Now what?
Now shoot this guy.
I got you guys, too.
Reloading.
Mission complete!
Nice!
Mission complete.
Easy.
Let's go.
Now we just run.
We're heading to the next area.
Yep, I'm just done with it.
What do you mean we don't fly?
White hair is from stress.
He's already white-haired.
Jump!
There's fall damage.
I got the turret.
Oh!
An explosion killed me.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No!
I got you.
I don't know.
An explosion.
What just killed us?
I don't know.
An explosion.
I think it was RPR's thingy.
No, it wasn't.
It was something from behind us.
Yeah, something exploded.
I got hit by it, too, but we're fine now.
It's okay.
Well, I'm not.
I'm dead.
We have reinforcements.
Reinforcements.
We got rocketed from behind.
Han?
It's Zeller.
Oh, it's Han.
How did he do that?
He's so cheeky right now.
He's a cheeky little guy.
I didn't do that.
The moment he used that voice, that voice right there, you know.
You know.
He used that voice.
Listen.
If the world hates me, maybe I'll hate the world.
He lived long enough to become a villain.
Okay, Kevin.
You're not.
He's dead.
Wait, it's coming from the south.
There's a huge tower that's been shooting us.
That's what shot us then.
It's coming from the south.
It sure is.
Don't pick that tower.
That's too strong.
Oh god.
We have to live for one minute.
Han!
Han, do you have enough heals?
We're good.
Are we?
I'm gonna try to orbital it.
What the?
I don't think you can orbital it.
Oh no.
I'm so scared.
Han!
Don't be scared.
We must do this.
It's up to you.
Han Solo!
It's up to you!
Holy shit!
Look at him go!
Oh shit, from the front as well.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, they're everywhere.
They're everywhere.
Holy shit, look at this gamer!
Why is he gaming?
You have no stims.
He has no more stims.
20 seconds!
Run to the fort.
What are you doing?
Gathering my breath.
He's so fucked.
He is so fucked.
We're gonna be alright.
5 seconds.
What the fuck?
Holy shit.
Go, go, go, go!
No!
Oh wait, can he?
This guy is an anime protagonist!
Clutch your kid!
He's an anime protagonist!
Holy shit, he's cooking!
Those 10 hours!
He's a gamer!
Oh my god, he's like...
He's glitching.
Oh, he got shot in the crotch!
Oh my god.
What are you doing?
Why are you just holding the camera?
Why are you holding that out?
Oh my god!
It would be so sad if RPR dies.
Mr. RPR just chill before he finds Solo.
He has no meds and no nothing.
It would be so sad if RPR dies.
While Zelen has lived for so long.
I'm not gonna die, okay?
I'm a professional.
That's a flag right there, bro.
Mother, RPR is the type of guy who's gonna die.
I'm gonna tell the fucking dude next to him.
After this war, let's go back happily to our family.
He died!
I told you!
RPR worked so hard for this!
Holy shit!
RPR, what happened?
RPR worked so hard for you to live!
As soon as I said that phrase, RPR worked so hard for you to live!
After this war, let's go back to our family now.
I juked myself a little bit, but you fucking fucked me until the end.
I'm not gonna lie, RPR got me dead.
Oh my god.
You just made the jinxed enchantment stronger.
It's extraction!
You might as well have all the life, girl!
What?!
You stepped on the smelly bomb.
Go go go!
Just run!
That's the plan.
Forixx seconds, and you get the bestie main- Who, me?
The soaps hasn't team killed anybody.
Dude, leave it to me bro.
I got you man.
How do you guys know 15 seconds and shit?
Cause it's on the top left!
Oh, I'm back bitches.
Leave it to me.
Well no, if it's Zeller I don't really wanna bring him back.
Apparently the one that's like a one day away from retirement.
What the fuck is this bot drop?
Why are they calling me a bot bro?
Zeller, do not land on Han.
He worked so hard to get here.
Uh oh.
Are you healed up?
Yeah, yeah, he's healed up.
He's good now.
Oh my god, just 1 minute and 36 seconds.
Just keep going to extraction point.
You're so close.
Actually don't even know.
We're not close, we still have to wait 2 minutes.
Not very good.
You know what?
Maybe I don't need you anymore.
No!
Put him down all the other style.
Just like as the ship is dropping down, you're like, you know what?
This was a solo mission.
I'm just gonna spectate Zeller's because I know he's gonna provide content.
Fuck you mean?
I ain't got no content.
How do I slide?
It's alt.
It's alt, you mean like...
Oh shit, people in front of us guys.
Careful, careful, careful.
I wanna be careful but I can't.
There's an orbital strike, Zeller.
Be careful.
It's not hitting the single person I'm trying to shoot.
Wait, did he die?
Die!
Don't die, don't die, don't die.
Just run, just run, just run.
I'm out, I'm out, I'm out.
Just run, just run.
Dive you little bitch, dive you little bitch.
Why is there a fucking tank over here?
Just run, just run.
Go back.
I think you were better off solo.
Don't go back.
Zeller, don't go back.
Watch me.
10 seconds.
I'm back.
If you respawn me, I'm gonna be back and we're...
What do I do to respawn you, bro?
We're like the dream team.
Do it now, do it now.
Okay.
Respawn, how the fuck do I respawn?
Lift up.
So close.
Okay, so you know how you were subbing strategies?
It's so hard.
So, I'll just...
No!
Heal, heal, heal.
Heal, heal.
I can't keep you.
No, he's dead.
She's dead.
Heal, die.
Heal.
You're dead.
We're back!
No!
Oh no!
Doki, you're a final hug.
Oh you're alone.
Oh god, oh god.
You're alone, buddy.
Don't feel alone.
I don't wanna be alone.
Doki1, Kenobi, you're our only hug.
Oh, we're so...
We were doing so good, and then...
We were doing so good, I don't wanna be alone.
You were not doing good at all, you killed him.
I'm so scared!
One minute, one minute, one minute.
Okay, okay.
Doki won Kenobi is crazy.
It's okay.
There's no robots coming in.
We're fine.
We can chill.
There's no one coming in.
There's nobody here.
There's a robot right there.
No, it's not.
Where?
Just crouch in the corner.
Be a rat, you know.
Just rat in the corner.
Show your superiority.
There's nobody here.
Thank god they all shot Zeller before they saw him.
Hell yeah!
I took all the hate.
I took all the aggro for you.
Doki, apparently you don't know how to use the map.
You have to press tab.
I do, I just follow you guys.
Okay, we're the map.
Okay, got it.
I'm the map.
I don't need to look at the map if you guys can look at the map for me.
Yeah, that's what teammates are for.
Look at that.
I'm doing the best.
You know what?
I think I've done the best out of all of you guys.
I have nobody on me.
It's the safest we've ever been.
You've got a point.
Yeah, nobody's here.
Oh...
No...
Oh shit!
Oh no...
Two seconds until...
Yeah!
Go RPR, go!
It's like Pokemon!
I'm gonna land on her.
Two more minutes until Han Solo, the strongest member, comes back.
The strongest man in the team comes back.
We have Doki, one Kenobi.
We have RPR, 2D2.
Just RPR.
RPR.
RPR2D2.
How the fuck am I R2D2?
There's dropships, by the way.
Doki, one Kenobi.
I'm coming back!
I'm coming over!
That's a lot of robots over there!
Where do I go?
R2D2, where do I go?
Kill them!
Okay, do not call me R2D2.
Beep, beep, beep!
Zenlo Binks.
Who is that?
I don't even know.
I've never watched a Star Wars series.
Oh, Zenlo Binks is like the strongest character in Star Wars.
He's like a Sith Lord.
Yeah, he's a Sith Lord.
He's a Sith Lord!
They're chasing RPR!
Run!
Run, Doki!
RPRs!
Oh, they're coming from behind as well!
It's okay, I got one.
You got one only?
I got one, guys!
I did my part!
Zenlo Luribinks.
Okay, I got two.
I'm burning, I'm burning, I'm burning!
How are you burning?
You have one second!
30 more seconds!
30 more seconds before we have the actual carry!
Okay.
You know what?
I'm gonna leave you then.
You can wait for him.
I'm gonna go fucking do the rest.
Wait, what?
What do you mean?
You're waiting for the carry, right?
You don't need me.
You need to get carried too!
I don't carry, so I'm just gonna go do the mission.
Yeah, but you need to get carried.
You should stay near us so Han Solo can carry us.
No, no, no, I'm fine.
You guys got that.
Are you reinforcing him?
No, no, you reinforce him.
He needs the help.
I got you, Han Solo.
Thank you, thank you.
Why do these guys explode in flames?
I remember who got you.
Oh my god!
Oh shit, watch out!
That's fine.
Okay, let's go.
Let's go back to RPR.
Let's go back to R2-D2.
No!
You guys don't need me, right?
So we reinforced everybody, so everybody's good, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Everybody's good.
Everybody's good, right?
I will kill you!
Dead cat talk.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm heading over, I'm heading over, I'm trying to run, I have no more stamina!
Right here.
I'm almost there.
Woo!
You're the R2-D2, what the fuck?
Doki D2.
Oh god.
I'm burning, but I'm fine.
I'm heading over to R2-D2.
Let's go southwest, southwest.
40 seconds and then we'll have another respawn for one of us!
And I'll be back.
And I will carry you guys once again.
Hey R2-D2, we're here.
Yeah, we have problems.
Wait, I like how you acknowledge that you're R2-D2.
You responded to that.
I'm never R2-D2ing again.
Can the railgun not break these?
Oh!
Are you okay?
The tower, the tower, careful, the tower!
On the entrance point, yeah.
Oh shit, oh shit, I'm running away, I'm running away.
You have an orbital that you can shoot that thing with.
Okay, yeah, yeah, I do, I do.
I do.
Give me a sec, I need to remember how to do this.
Uh...
Oh no!
I missed it from behind!
I'm going across the map, holy crap.
What happened?
I got shot by the laser.
He got tower, no!
I got tower too!
RPA, prove to us that you're the carry.
Come on!
RPA!
Reinforce me!
Yeah, well you got me if you reinforce me, yo!
You want me to go land on the guy?
Land on the tower, land on the tower.
Okay, let's see if my aim can...
Let's see if my aim is good enough to land on the tower, bro.
Don't land on me, please.
Where the fuck?
I can't, bro!
This is impossible.
Oh shit.
Okay.
He's got no aim.
And no bitches.
Dude, I was so far away from the...
Alright, what about a grenade for the tower?
No, no, that will not work.
Okay.
It doesn't work, yeah, I tried.
Holy shit!
He's shit!
Did he just sound shit?
Oh, I'm burning, I'm burning, I'm burning!
Heal yourself, heal!
Heal, heal, heal!
You're doing so well!
You're doing so well, Seller!
This is my last reload.
Do you not have resupply?
Nope, it's over there, look at it.
I'll get the resupply!
Come to me, come to me!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, Seller!
Seller, Seller, Seller, there's a tank behind our PR!
Do not go behind him!
Okay.
Where's the extraction point?
Why aren't you guys going to extraction?
We don't need these extra...
Guys, what do I do?
Run, run, run, run, Seller, Seller, Seller!
Run and heal!
Just like how Han did!
Just run and heal!
No, there's a tree!
Don't run towards them!
He's gonna die to the tower!
No, he's not!
Just keep running!
Run away from them!
Get away!
Even if we miss this, even if we miss this, there's gonna be an emergency one!
So just stay alive!
We didn't finish the mission!
We did!
We just need extraction!
20 seconds!
20 seconds and you get Han Solo back!
You're gonna run out of bounds!
No!
I hate this game!
Why am I out of bounds?
That's not out of bounds!
So it's like...
10 seconds!
Bring me in, coach!
Don't worry!
The carry's coming back soon!
Get the carry in!
What the fuck is he...
Bring me in!
I wanna try!
Give me a second!
Oh my god...
Okay, okay.
I gotta go this way.
Give me a second, okay?
Oh fuck!
Leave me alone!
I did nothing!
Ah!
I'm coming back in!
He's coming!
Oh no!
It's me!
It's Han!
Okay, thank god!
Oh thank god!
One minute!
One minute and 50 seconds!
You got this, Han!
You can do this again!
Where's the extract?
I tried my best!
Bro, that was out of zone!
I couldn't... I got cornered!
I got cornered!
You did that to yourself, bro!
No I didn't!
They didn't tell me which way to go, man!
We can't see the map when we're dead!
Han's still out!
I don't care!
I like how... I like how like...
Han comes down and everybody...
There's no enemies after that.
He's just chilling.
One minute left!
Oh shit!
Wait!
Wait a minute!
You have to head there in one minute!
Wait, isn't this the extraction point?
Wait, you will not be able to...
You will not be able to...
Res anyone because the reinforce and the ship leaves the stratosphere at the same time.
So... Oh no!
It's literally the same time.
It's a four minute defense!
I think we already failed.
Salutations!
I think we already failed a mission!
Four minutes of quality content!
Right here!
Okay, I blame RPR for not taking us to extraction.
You wouldn't do the bonus mission.
What?
It's not... It's my fault that you guys kept team killing each other for 15 deaths.
We did!
We're not team killing each other!
We were not team killing each other!
No, imagine that!
The difficulty was just too hard for us.
Okay?
Okay, the copium and the gas lighting.
Oh no!
The destroyer has left!
That's good!
We are the destroyer!
Oh what?
I thought they were the bad guys.
We're the reinforcements!
That's great!
Well look!
They can't find him!
Uh oh!
I wonder if they know where he is.
They have wall hacks!
This isn't fair!
It's okay!
Just keep running!
Just keep running for two minutes and 30 seconds!
See, this is what happened to me!
They cornered me like this, man!
Wait, where are you shooting?
Oh no!
You don't have enough stims for this!
Wait, how many stims do you have left?
Two.
Why do they only give us four stims?
These guys are stingy, man.
They should give us like 99 stims.
Can you not see what armor we're wearing?
I don't know.
Make the stims more compact, I guess.
I believe.
I believe in him.
RPR, why don't you believe in him?
Do I have to say that I believe in him?
Yes!
Of course!
He knows I believe in him!
Now he does!
And now he's dead.
Maybe he shouldn't have believed in him.
Why did you believe in him?
You jinxed him!
Oh my god!
Han Solo...
What the fuck?
Where did your head go?
Where did it go?
He got no head.
Mission completed.
Han Solo couldn't clutch anymore.
You couldn't clutch it.
I blame...
You know what?
I blame R2D2.
Yeah, same.
Yeah, our super citizen wasn't so super.
Yeah.
He looked like a free to play player to me.
I was like shit!
One Zeller died and started screaming.
I'm getting tea bags!
You fucking shit!
Zellick!
I did it!
Bro!
Look at me.
Only 50 friendly fire damage.
Bro!
62k is crazy.
I don't care!
How did you get to 6000?
I don't know man.
I don't know.
Oh my god.
But look!
Shots fired.
1456.
Yeah and 1400 of them were at us.
Yeah.
No!
Come on guys.
What do you mean come on?
That's not a lie!
That's just terrible.
Holy shit.
That's no fucking lie!
Come on.
12 times.
12 of our respawns were on him.
Hey, your fault for killing me.
If you guys let me live, you know?
What do you mean our fault?
Who killed you?
Who was it?
You guys all killed me.
What do you mean?
Who hurt you?
Alright, let's see.
Oh, I'm gonna have a machine gun sentry.
Oh my god, I'm gonna buy a gatling sentry.
I got a vitality enhancement so we can live.
Nice.
What does that mean?
Like you don't die as fast.
Oh shit!
So it applies to all of us?
Yeah.
So I can shoot Zeller 3 times instead.
Nice.
So now you can...
Oh my god, Zeller can...
Zeller can break 10k.
Wait, I want a rifle.
I want a rifle.
Are rifles strong or are they weak?
Ummm...
What rifle are you using?
Shotgun is the best.
Oh, is it?
Which one is that?
Somebody said RPR Viagra.
Whoa!
Vitality enhancement.
What?
Dude, someone has the helipad one, right?
Helldiver, the helipad.
Fuck, fuck, fuck.
Yeah, I have the helipad one.
I have the helipad one.
Where are we going?
Here?
Where do we go?
Here.
Uh, we'll buy this one.
Because you have to do this too.
So we can do the rocket.
So let's do this one.
I got sentry!
I'm gonna go with auto-cannon this time.
I think auto-cannon is stronger against automatons.
I'm gonna bring a shield generator.
I'm gonna bring my turret.
I'm gonna bring the only two that I have.
What did you have?
He has a shield.
He has the orbital and the machine gun.
You know you can buy stuff?
I'm pretty sure you have enough money to buy things now.
I didn't know you could buy stuff.
Did you put the helipad optimization in?
Yeah, I did.
Okay, good.
That one allows you to respawn with full ammo and shit.
I got two mortars.
One EMS, one actual mortar.
So...
I have...
I have machine gun.
I have a gatling gun!
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have a sentry now.
You wanna go to a what?
I don't have to shoot my gun.
I can let these guys do it for me.
Alright, machine gun!
Woah, woah, that's so far away.
Holy shit.
Alright, give me a sec.
I'm grabbing my machine gun.
RPO, you wanna see something funny?
Yeah.
What's the funny thing?
I'm not gonna do it.
Coward.
I went down, I went down.
Coward, do it!
Not me, not me, not me, not me.
I got a machine gun too, guys.
Do it, but two others.
Oh shit.
That's a little patrol.
I shot the guy that called for reinforcements.
So it should be.
Nevermind.
Nice.
The bot drop detected.
You did it, RPR.
Is that what you were trying to do?
There was two of them, okay?
At least I shot one of them.
Did you shoot one?
No, you didn't.
Yes, but you're a super citizen.
You should have been able to shoot both.
I'm not super citizen right now.
So that tags a lie?
So you gave up your citizenship?
Oh, you're a traitor.
Oh my god, you're not here for democracy and liberty?
I'm just gonna not talk to you guys.
I'm just gonna focus on shooting.
Guys, shoot the back!
Wait, wait, wait.
What do you mean?
There's nobody in the back.
Oh, this guy.
I'm reloading.
Are you okay, Han?
I'm good.
I knew he was fine.
I have the power of friendship.
Yay!
Why can't you have the power of friendship?
Wait, wait, wait.
This side.
350, 350, 350.
Don't worry.
I'm shooting my gun.
We're good.
Everything's good.
There's some bullshit by us.
I gotta reload!
Where do we go?
Here, on me.
See, this is why I don't need to look at my map.
I can just follow you.
She's screaming something.
We're super!
Yeah!
I need more bullets.
Here, here.
It's right here.
Right here, right where?
Right here, right here.
Right here, right now.
Oh, is that bullet?
Bro, he slapped me.
No, I didn't.
I missed.
Bro, he hit me.
What?
Oh, my God.
I'm gonna cancel you right now.
Yeah.
Oh, shit.
Make it X longer.
Oh, I'm dead.
Flames are on the same floor.
I just got one shot by that.
Oh, we need a save.
Oh, you have...
Someone res.
Well, I'm taking him on a walk.
I got you.
Uh...
I'm taking Mr. Flamethrower on a walk.
Oh, it's a Hulk.
Oh, no!
I'm shooting his back.
I killed him.
I took him on a walk.
Dude, I clutched up there, baby.
See, I told you.
Yeah, I just watched Ducky literally sit in front of me and tank the flamethrower.
I take that for you.
I did that for you.
I aggroed it.
Activate the transformer.
Where do we go?
Gotta activate this transformer.
There's a reloaded machine gun here.
I'll just do everything, guys.
Yay!
He did it.
He did everything.
Let's go!
Alright, next up.
Alright, sweet.
Great teamwork, baby.
Let's go.
We're a good team, RPO.
Yeah, great teamwork.
Dude, I was fucking that flamethrower guy from the back.
Holy shit, man.
We're so good at this game.
Grenading.
Can I not auto-canon this thing?
I thought I could.
I got you.
Can I get up here?
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
I'm turning around.
Someone said this might be my favorite group of idiots.
Look to the left!
Holy shit!
Oh, I did it!
There's a fucking horde of them coming over here.
Wait, where?
Grenade!
That's a scout!
That was a huge nade.
Okay.
I practiced so much by blowing you guys up.
I'm so used to these grenades now.
Leave it to me, yo.
You just detected a huge horde to us.
Dude, you practiced by blowing?
Do you also swallow?
No, I don't swallow.
No, I will never.
Holy shit, guys!
Wait, wait, there's a big guy!
I'm slipping!
I might die.
Zeller, we left you.
You guys are horrible!
You killed me!
Who killed you?
After all I've done.
After all I did to you.
No!
Oh, you suck so much dick.
Spawn us in.
You guys killed me!
I'm back.
Bro, leave it to me, yo.
Oh, we got spotted by the flamethrower!
No!
I'm fucking in the back!
Nice!
We did it, we did it!
He fucked him in the back.
Oh, shit!
How was it?
Not even close.
Not even close, baby!
Next stop is this big red area right here.
Let's go.
Alright, nice.
Alright, where is that?
Follow me.
Alright, guys, I need machine gun ammo, if anybody has extra ammo.
Let me get you with a resupply.
Nice!
Oh my god, our peer discovered heavy outposts and he also died.
Let's play resupply chicken.
Resupply chicken, let's go.
Oh!
No!
You're a bigger chicken than I am!
That's three hawks, that's three hawks.
I nuclear bombed it.
That's four hawks, that's four hawks.
Oh wait, there's even more, there's even more, there's even more!
We're coming over, we're coming over!
I exploded a bunch of them, but they didn't die to a nuclear fucking bomb.
Hello?
It's okay, I'm gonna flank around.
Guys, it's okay, I'm...
Oh no, they're all focused on me.
Oh god, oh god, oh god, okay, it's okay, I'm machine gunning.
I got a nuclear bomb as well.
Nuclear orbit, I dropped it.
How did you have a bomb?
An orbit, an orbit, I threw it, I threw it.
I don't have anything to do with it though.
Oh my god, I got rocketed in my ass.
Oh shit!
Oh god.
It's okay, I have a, I have a Eagle cluster.
I'm throwing it.
I think I did something, I think I did something.
I killed the cannon, I killed the cannon here.
Eagle cluster on my ass?
What do you mean it's helpful?
It's coming down!
You killed me!
Tom and Zillr got eagle clustered by Doki.
That was some sick moves.
I said, I called out my eagle cluster.
I killed the flamethrower guy though.
I killed one.
At that point you might as well just be like, I'm gonna kill you, I'm gonna kill you, I'm gonna kill you.
I'm gonna kill you, I'm gonna kill you.
Yeah, but you guys still didn't know it was happening.
Oh no, I landed right in front of the mess of flames!
I'm gonna throw...
It's okay, I'm fucking killing him.
We're good, he's dead.
There's two more though.
Okay guys, I'm gonna put an orb on our strike this time.
There's two more of these motherfuckers.
Wait, I have the gallon gun!
Use it then, will you?
I use it!
We both said the same thing.
It's coming down!
I'm helping!
You throw me one!
Yeah, that was very helpful.
Just give the enemy the fucking weapon as well next time.
No, it's my gallon gun!
Turret!
I got you!
It's a turret!
It's helping!
Oh my god, I'm so helpful.
Yes it is, look at him, he's shooting the thing.
Look at him shoot!
Look at him go!
Oh my god, oh my god!
Oh my god!
There's so many things!
There's one more Hulk.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Not today, bitches!
Nice, nice, let's go!
We did it!
We're doing it!
We killed all the Hulks, now we kill the small trash now.
And then we'll resupply, because holy fuck.
We did it!
We're doing our part.
This motherfucker fly!
I'm gonna do an orbital over there.
There's another one!
Wait, I have enough for ego strike!
Yeah, orbital!
I'm throwing it, I'm throwing it!
Eagle strike!
I'm running too!
I'm gonna run, I'm gonna run!
I'm gonna kill you right now!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm going to kill you right now!
I'm so proud of you!
One more, one more and you still didn't die!
That was not mine!
I'll shoot the back!
Okay, I'll sit here and look pretty then.
I am heading over.
What the fuck is this?
He's throwing me around!
I'm grenade?
I'm nading?
Oh no, he's looking at me now!
Nice!
Nice, nice, nice!
Nice grenade!
Guys, we're getting naded from the west.
Oh shit, okay.
I'm in the stars, sorry.
Okay.
Holy fuck, this is bad.
RPR, where do we go?
Wait, I'm dealing with the rest of this trash here.
We can help!
Yeah, shoot his right leg without the cannon.
That's okay, I threw a nade.
Right leg without a cannon, huh?
Nice.
We did it!
There's still one more.
Yeah, he's like all the way up in front of us.
Got you, I'm flanking him.
Don't worry, I'm flanking him with you.
He won't expect two flankers.
I am in range of the enemy artillery.
There is a guy right in front of you.
I got him.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Alright, let's go, let's go, let's go.
Yeah!
We did it!
We did it.
More ammo, more ammo on me, ammo on me.
More ammo on you?
Where, where, where?
I'm over here, I'm over here.
Nice.
I have no more ammo.
Alright guys, next up we gotta go...
here.
Where's here?
Just fucking follow me, man.
You gotta babysit us.
Just fucking follow me.
Okay, okay, okay.
We're here, we're here, we're here.
Throwing resupply, resupply.
Oh my god, that's for us.
For us?
Did you fucking shoot me?
No, we're shooting people behind us.
No, why would we ever shoot you?
Yeah, why would we?
We're a team.
You guys don't do that ever.
Yeah, we don't.
Wow.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, the fucking bombs.
They're flying over here.
Where?
Mortar strike.
Coming in.
Careful.
This resupply is bugged.
No, I got one.
No!
I cannot get one.
There's people behind us.
I'm needing, I'm needing, I'm needing.
They're dead, they're dead, they're dead.
What is this?
What is this resupply?
I don't know, you're the one that put it down there.
Dude, the bombs are nutty.
Yo, this is on you.
This is actually on you.
Oh, that's fine.
Yeah, why didn't we do that?
We gotta go, we gotta go.
Go, go, go, go.
Are we gonna arouse this guy?
Oh wait, he said, when did he die?
The bomb hit him.
When did he die?
Okay.
Nice.
Oh, we need, we need resupply.
I have another day.
Wait, how did you die?
Oh no.
I got, I got, I got two shield boys on me.
Two shield boys.
Wait, how are we gonna get to the boys?
Just res me, just res me.
I res you, I res you.
Where's the shield boys?
Right next to the spawner.
Gotcha.
I just died.
As soon as you landed?
Inside my health pod.
I'm so proud of you sacrificing one for the team.
Thank you for your, thank you for your sacrifice, RPR.
You really had it.
Yay freedom!
Freedom!
I'm so proud of you.
You did it!
The real citizen.
We did it!
How does that even?
Oh, there's more.
Oh, he's shooting at us right now.
Careful, careful, careful.
Careful.
That's wild.
That's an artillery shooting at us.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm trying to get away from that right now.
I'm back.
Where's the artillery?
I guess you guys don't wanna...
It's right here.
We should extract, guys.
We should extract.
We could get rid of all of this red stuff on the map.
We have nine lives.
Yo, fuck this cannon.
We have nine lives, we can do this.
Look on the right, look on the right.
Go kill that fucking spawner on the right.
Okay, okay, us three on the right.
Where are you gonna go, RPR?
Where are you gonna go?
I'm gonna go to the left.
Oh, god.
Wait, wait, I have enough for Eagle Cluster.
Eagle Cluster, Eagle Cluster, Eagle Cluster.
Oh, no.
Run, run, run, run, run, run.
No, no, no, no.
Okay, don't worry, I got you.
I won't throw you into the Eagle Cluster.
You could, I wouldn't really.
Nice, nice, nice, nice.
It's okay, it's God.
Did we?
Yeah, we did.
Yep.
Nice.
Nice, Eagle Cluster.
Don't take my E, just yoink it right in front of me, you evil, evil man, you evil, evil man.
Ah!
Doki, no!
What the fuck?
I'm totally not in this thing.
Okay, okay.
How do I, how do I drop this, how do I drop this, bro?
I forget.
Oh, there we go, here you go, you got it, here you go.
I picked up Doki's wish- AHH!
Democracy has led!
There's so many people!
I'm back, bitches!
Come back!
How are you guys dying all the time?
What's going on?
You left us alone!
I'm here!
Now look what's going on!
Bring me back!
I mean, you can show how fucking hard I can handle you guys.
Right?
We can't take care of ourselves.
Right, hun?
Hun?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, you got that, right?
Yeah, we're good, we're good.
Hun, where am I?
Yeah!
Jesus Christ!
Come back!
Come back, you serial killer!
Bring me back!
Welcome back.
I'm back, I'm back guys.
There's a scary dude near our PR.
It's like nothing happened.
Oh, a Hulk!
Alright, where do we go?
Yo, yo, how do I use this?
Keep running in circles, keep running in circles!
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep!
It's okay!
Nade!
I got it!
Nice!
We did it!
Where's the strategy?
We gotta go get these sentry guns.
Fuck, these things are... OH MY GOD!
OH MY GOD!
Guys, we gotta get that turret.
We gotta get that turret, guys.
How do we get that turret?
I'm trying.
I can go for a solo mission, I got you.
Point me towards the...
What?!
Point me towards it.
It turns over there!
It's...
OH!
Please, please, please!
I think I got the turret with this one.
Not again, not again, not again!
I'm going with you, our PR.
We got this.
I'm so scared.
I'm just gonna hide behind... did you get it?
Did you get the turret?
Nice, one turret's dead, one turret's dead, one turret's dead over here.
Okay, okay, I can ego strike.
I can ego strike.
If all else fails, I have ego clustering.
Oh shit, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck, I'm stuck!
Eagle cluster!
Nice.
Oh, there's an AT&T behind us.
I'm gonna orbital strike this.
Orbital strike.
What the hell was that?
Yeah, yeah, I almost strike my ass, I'm dead.
Wow, my strike hasn't even hit yet.
Well, it wouldn't kill me then.
I don't know that it hasn't even hit yet, that wasn't mine!
Okay.
Where's the other turret?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't think there is a turret, it's an artillery thing.
How do we get rid of the artillery?
We gotta find it, and then just pull it.
Oh, we could just leave.
Wait.
Well, I mean, yeah, but...
You know, what's the fun in that?
We have three more rebats.
I mean, it's dying, it's dying!
No, no, no, no, no, no!
No!
The fucking turret!
Why?
Hey guys!
I am right here!
Wait, I can like, can I...
If I land on the robot, does it do damage?
Yeah, it kills it, it kills it.
I'll mark it, oh, it's dead, it's dead.
Boom!
You're welcome, guys.
Hey, welcome on in.
Oh, four damage by me, chaps!
Wow!
Guys, we have two reinforcements left, guys.
Okay, let's go to the objective.
Let's go here.
Alright, alright, alright, I'm following you, hun.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go!
I see the artillery.
I'll get rid of the artillery.
Yay, I believe in your RPR.
You can do this for us.
Oh, it's not that way?
Okay.
I believe less in you now.
I gotta go around.
They still kind of believe in me, right?
Oh, I thought you were getting rid of the artillery.
What is this?
There's so many guys, it sounds like Cossacks in this game.
Holy shit.
Okay.
Okay, um...
AHH!
Um...
Who the fuck are you?
So, are you reinforcing me?
Are you reinforcing him?
Let me do it.
Yeah, there's a lot of people on me right now.
Okay, I got you.
Okay, okay, okay.
I have a bunch of them on me.
This is okay.
I'm heading over to you.
Nice, nice, nice.
Cover up and appreciate if you need to.
It's okay, it's okay.
I made them run around in a circle, so we're fine.
I got the nade.
Nade down.
I got one only.
Okay, I'm heading back.
I'm nading, I'm nading, I'm nading.
Careful, careful.
We run back.
Nice, nice, nice.
We're doing it.
Behind us, behind us.
North, north, north.
There's an auto-cannon.
Oh my god, I almost fucking...
Let's go northeast, okay?
Northeast.
Okay.
Oh, no.
Oh, no, it's fine, it's fine, it's fine.
I'm okay.
We have last reinforce.
Hun, you got that, Hun?
Yep.
I'm gonna throw a nade behind us.
Yo, up here is just chillin', bro.
Bro, we have all of the botas.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Seller, run.
Follow me.
Yes, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running.
Just run.
Don't aggro anybody that you don't need to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just keep running.
Oh my god, we did it!
We got the artillery!
Good job, guys.
We did it, guys!
We did it, okay?
Yeah, we're a team.
We're a team.
We aggroed the rest of the bot.
We were the distractions.
Yeah, we're the distractions.
Yeah, we did our job.
Yeah, no, you guys did great.
Good job, guys.
Run this way so you don't aggro those big guys.
Alright, alright, alright.
Oh, I got shot in the foot.
It's okay.
They didn't see us.
They don't see us.
We don't have any of the aggro.
Oh, oh, oh.
We going in.
Or we going sneaky-beaky like?
Where is... Oh my gosh, the extraction is so far.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're gathering more reinforcements anyway.
Oh no, they saw us.
On?
What did you do?
What did you do, Han?
We did it!
Yeah, you guys did this as well.
It was crazy.
You guys keep doing it.
It's crazy.
We're doing it.
I'm actually dead to fire.
I'm not actually.
I'm alive somehow.
I lived.
Wait, you don't have any stims?
I'm calling a resupply just to get stims.
Because I don't.
We're all good.
We resupply by dying.
Yeah, exactly.
Good job guys.
You can count on us.
We never need a resupply.
We just keep coming back.
Exactly.
Legends never die.
Here we go.
Where do we go?
Is it...
Oh, is this the...
Is this the...
Is this extra?
Oh, do you just take us to extra instead of extraction?
No, this is what we have to do.
We have to launch the missile.
Can you guys unlock that down there?
Okay, yeah, I can do that.
Ow, I took fall damage.
Oh, shit.
Save my fucking kneecaps.
I got this.
I'll go from left.
You go from right.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
We got two.
Okay.
Okay, now we're just gonna...
We're gonna have to stand in the middle of it.
We have one reinforcement.
Don't be a coward.
Watch this.
Okay, actually, no.
There's actually fucking guys next to us.
Wait a minute.
Oh, they're jumping on me.
Oh, they can fly.
Oh, what an explosion killed me.
What?
You guys have one res.
You guys are fine.
Oh, no.
But what about me?
I wanted that res.
Oh, god.
Okay, this way.
Come up here.
Actually, don't come up here.
Don't come up here.
Okay, I'm not coming over.
I'm not coming over.
Nice landing.
You guys are doing great.
You guys are gonna live.
You guys are gonna survive.
We're gonna live.
I believe in us.
Okay.
Oh, no.
There's a robot.
There's a shield.
Yeah, there's a shield.
I'm gonna throw my nade.
I don't have nades.
I'm shooting him in the cross.
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm dropping my nade.
I dropped the nade.
I'm going to go.
Oh, my goodness.
That's so bad.
Run, run, run, run.
Run, run, run.
I'm trying my best to run.
Just run.
He's coming in.
I lost so many frames there.
So, we did it.
The eagle worked.
Nice.
That actually worked.
Yeah, that actually worked.
Shit.
No.
Oh, that was dangerous.
Oh boy, I dodged it last minute.
Oh my god.
Han, was that...
You guys are going through war and I'm over here just...
That was not me.
Just chilling.
Han...
It was the red one.
It was the enemies.
It wasn't me.
I can't stand for this abuse.
Wow!
Han, Han, remember everything we've done.
Remember all the things we've done.
Remember all the bots we killed together.
I just met you!
Yeah, today's the first time we met, you know?
In the last two hours!
Remember what you...
Remember...
The last two hours!
Today's the first day we met.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Yeah, and now we're as close as ever.
War...
War makes strong bonds.
Brothers in arms.
We're brothers in arms.
Remember that.
I will say like...
You guys are alive for longer than I thought you would be.
Did I do it?
Oh, I did it.
I think.
Yeah, we did it.
Whoa!
Five.
Oh, we also have a resupply.
We should...
We can call it a resupply.
One.
Yay!
Blast off!
Resupply is coming in.
So, RPR doesn't get it.
I don't...
Okay.
She got...
I mean, I got all these down.
That's kind of mean.
After everything I've done for you guys, she's like, Yeah, let's just fuck them.
Hey, we got the nuclear!
The launch codes!
We did that.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And all the fucking sight objectives.
Yeah, but...
That's better sight objectives.
Get UA's.
So, by blasting that one...
We're not gonna be staying there when the money comes in.
Let's go.
Yay!
Dang, I should really watch the Starship Trooper movies again.
This shit kinda hurts.
Is that how you wanna watch it with me?
I've never watched it before.
I've never watched it either.
I've watched that first one you make.
Oh my gosh, we should watch it together after dinner.
After dinner?
Yeah.
We're gonna be like, oh, there's people shooting at us.
Oh.
Nice.
Good job, RPR.
Yeah, we did it!
Thank you.
We're all here.
There's like a guy in red.
Look to your left, guys.
There's a spawner over there on the left side.
Oh yeah, look at that.
I'm gonna reload my gun real fast.
Whoa!
What was that?
Was that another artillery?
No, it was the wrong guy.
Oh, okay.
He's dead now.
Okay.
He's gotten murdered.
Whoa!
Something is shooting us.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's a cannon.
That's literally a cannon right in front of me.
There's literally a cannon right in front of me.
Does anybody have an orbital strike on that thing?
I do!
I got it, I got it, I got it.
I got it too.
I think, I think, I got it.
I got it, I got it.
Leave it to me.
You already put it down?
Yeah, I put it down, put it down, put it down.
Oh, shit, bitch.
I'm right near the cannon.
I'm gonna die, yo.
It's okay, it's okay.
You'll be fine.
Just don't look at it.
It ain't okay, fine.
If you don't look at it, you'll be fine.
Cool, dude, don't look at explosions.
Nice.
I don't know... oh.
Oh, yeah, just a small army got spawned on me.
It's all good.
I see it.
It's not on us, so it's okay.
I don't think it's destroyed.
I'm gonna go destroy it.
Run down straight, guys.
I don't think the tower got destroyed yet.
I threw another one over there.
Be careful.
All right, it's fine.
We're not looking at it.
Wait, so where is the...
Where is the extraction?
Pinged it right here.
All right, we'll follow you, Hod.
See that little orange?
Whoa!
No, I do not.
.
Little orange arrow on the top.
Wait, is this supply?
What's this?
Hey, guys, I need a reinforced...
Oh, metal.
I stole the metal.
Oh, it's okay.
It's all of us.
We all get it.
Everyone gets it.
Yeah, I was gonna say we all get it.
No, you just look like a bad person.
Oh, we have... there's ammo.
There's grenades.
Oh.
Nice.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
RPI used our reinforcements?
Yeah, I used one out of the...
.
What do you mean?
The ones that we used.
Wow, I can't believe you wasted our one.
Guys, I'm stuck.
Don't go that way.
Don't go that way, Sly.
I need help.
I need so much help.
Oh, he needs help, but he's dead anyways.
It's okay.
Yeah, we have a minute left.
There's so many samples there.
No.
That's all right.
Don't worry, guys.
Let's show them that we...
We don't need his guidance.
We're strong enough.
We're strong.
Babies together strong.
We don't want to play with you anymore.
Rip the samples, man.
I worked so hard for them bitches.
We're coming over, Han.
We're coming over.
Let's go.
Channel 8 bounce.
Oh my god, we're going to get extraction.
That's right.
We're going to get extraction.
I'm stuck.
Guys, stop.
.
This is going great.
Don't go that way.
Okay, easy, easy, easy.
See, we made it.
We made it.
30 seconds on each point.
Okay, okay, okay.
I have...
I also have a gun.
.
Gatling gun.
Here you go.
I know this will be helpful right here.
Oh, I can interact with these carts.
Yeah, it gives you information.
Do not operate.
No, I thought I could.
I thought I could ride on it.
It's like...
Oh, my favorite.
Oh, whoa.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
But we don't have the...
.
We don't have, like, extra lives for it.
We don't have extra lives for it.
Okay, okay.
No, you don't want to do that.
I got you.
.
After all the money I just made you, you don't want to respawn me.
It's crazy.
.
Whoa.
Whoa!
Shield generator!
What the fuck?
That's fucked up.
Can I shoot through this or do I...
Yes, you can shoot through it.
That's why it was like a Gibby shield.
It only lasts for a certain amount of time though.
How did I explode?
No!
I have samples!
Yeah, I'm trying to pick them out but it's not really going well for me.
So many fucking guys on me!
Oh my gosh.
Oh fuck!
Oh fuck me!
Guys, it's okay.
I'm watching from my dead body.
Guys!
In one minute I come back!
Don't worry!
I'm gonna throw the orbital strike in the center.
Guys, if I wasn't dead I could have killed my cluster.
Hopefully that's not something.
On the left!
Behind us!
Too far from extract...
Wait!
The shuttle is aborting in 12 seconds!
That's okay!
My body!
My fucking body!
It's already dead!
There's so many of these chainsaw bros.
Got him.
Got one.
Guys, don't worry.
I'm gonna land on a robot.
I'm gonna land on one of them.
Kobe!
Last reload!
Not good.
I'm coming in!
Oh wait, that's not me.
Sorry, I thought I was coming in.
Holy shit.
I thought you said you were gonna land on one of them.
You land on someone else.
That's crazy.
I'm out of ammo.
I'm out of ammo too.
Guys!
It's okay!
I have an eagle cluster.
Oh no.
Get me in there!
She has eagle cluster.
I have eagle cluster.
Don't worry!
Guys!
Guys?
I'm trying to...
I'm surviving!
I spawned her.
Nice.
Who died?
I got like three chainsaw guys on me, bro.
They want my ass so bad.
I got you.
I got no ass, man.
Nice.
I have eagle cluster.
I'm playing with a fucking handgun right now.
Focus the back.
I got the orbito.
There's a gun.
There's a gun here.
I'm getting fucked on.
I'm picking up the guns.
No!
Okay.
I'm gonna put out my gatling gun.
Oh fuck.
Run, Zelly!
Run!
Split up!
I'm splitting up.
I can't split up because the shuttle is inbound.
Okay.
There's the flamethrower guys on me.
Shuttle's approaching!
I'm throwing nades for you!
I'm going to the shuttle!
I'll be able to pick it.
Oh god.
I'm dodging all his moves right now.
Faker!
Guys, get in!
Get in!
No, no, no.
Wait 45 seconds.
Sorry, hun.
I see you don't care.
He did as well.
He does as well.
I couldn't make it.
No, but I distracted the flamethrower guys long enough.
He fucking...
He fucking killed me!
I held on to them.
Holy shit.
My last bullet in her head.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it.
I'm so proud of you, RPR.
Well done.
Space Shift Prime.
All the gets.
Gets it done, you know.
The one helldiver that got extracted.
The one true.
How many side missions I've done that...
You didn't do all of them.
Because someone decided to...
What happened to your teammates?
What teammates?
I went in alone.
We got four stars though.
We got four stars.
You're totally kidding.
That last fight felt like teamwork at the end there.
You know what I'm saying.
I know.
That was like a team play right there.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
There's definitely so much teamwork going on.
Well on our end, I don't know about you.
Yeah, we made it to the end.
I did nothing for the team at all.
My bad guys.
We did the main objective that progressed the game.
Look at this dude.
Look at this one guy.
Look at you guys dead on the side.
Don't talk to me.
Talk about the stats man.
Oh shit.
How are you consistently doing so much team damage?
I don't know.
I tried not to.
He died eight times again.
You got shots.
Look at your shots fired too.
Friendly fire damage.
But I have better accuracy than you.
I mean if you're shooting us, yeah your accuracy is higher.
Because you're shooting us.
Hell no.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That was crazy bro.
We did it guys.
I think we have one more.
You're literally ten kills above me.
We like tripled the fucking shots.
One more?
To finish this mission we have to do this.
We have to do this.
Oh wait.
Zeller come over here.
You need to upgrade your gear.
Come over here.
Go to here.
You guys have good gear.
And you guys are trying to compare to me.
Go to strategy gym and buy stuff.
What should I buy?
Oh my god there's anti-tank.
I'm gonna buy anti-tank.
Anti-tank?
I had 50 friendly fire damage.
It was me hatcheting the king.
No.
Yo, wait they have flamethrowers.
Shit.
Wooo.
Wait.
I can have anti-personnel minefield.
Does it like?
Oh that sounds horrible.
Does it affect you guys.
Does it?
Wow.
I'm gonna buy it.
Oh boy.
It's okay I'll buy the anti-tank.
I'll help.
We're the normal ones here.
I'm helping.
We're ready.
Wait, hold up, let me cook.
Wait, there's a flamethrower?
Wait, I want a flamethrower.
Where is that?
Oh, I'm too old.
It's level 10.
Wait, wait, wait.
Let me cook to have a board.
You have 24 seconds.
What am I gonna buy, bro?
What am I gonna buy?
Buy the mine.
Anti-personnel mine.
We're good.
Anti-personnel mine?
What is that?
It's the mine.
No, that's gonna kill us all, bro.
Get the mine.
What do you mean?
It's gonna kill us all.
No, it won't.
Believe in yourself.
I have a grenade launcher, though.
I might use the grenade launcher.
But this shit's so expensive.
6000 dollars.
Fucking bucks, bro?
You'll have enough.
We made a lot of money.
No, we did not.
Well, we're supposed to have made a lot of money.
I was able to buy like three things.
Where were you spending your money on, Zeller?
How about orbital...
Wait, I'm gonna get him and laugh.
Orbital...
Eagle cluster bomb.
Seems pretty cool.
Oh, no.
I worry about Zeller having more and more...
I have!
That's so good!
Eagle napalm airstrike.
I'm getting this one.
Oh, shit.
I wanna change my helmet.
Wait, where's the...
How do I buy stuff again?
Is it in the armory?
I press R.
Oh, I need a gun as well.
How much medals do I have?
Bro, I don't even have anything.
War bonds.
37.
You have to buy everything to unlock it?
Yeah.
Alright.
Move.
Wait.
This expendable anti-tank one, right?
This one, can you destroy turrets with it?
Can I unlock the homepage?
I think so, right?
Oh my god, I got finger guns!
Guys, we have to be...
What the fuck is a finger gun?
You get the shit from the fingers?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I got finger guns as my victory pose.
That's cheating.
Well, you...press R!
Press R!
It's literally in the battle pass.
Oh, you bought a battle pass.
No, it's free.
It's a free battle pass.
You're such an idiot.
You're supposed to use it.
Where's the free battle pass?
To get better weapons.
Press R.
Press R and then the...
Helldivers mobilize.
You buy guns here and stuff.
Oh, claim item.
Let's see...
Oh shit, I can claim everything!
Fuck!
Oh my god.
Do I unlock page 3?
I unlocked page 3!
Oh my god, I have a new helmet!
But I can have an orange cape!
So you know who I am.
Let's go!
I guess I'm gonna save up for the stamina enhancement.
That was pretty good.
Yeah, you're kinda lacking in that.
Yeah.
Look at my orange cape, guys.
Guys, I'm so cool now.
Look at me.
Helldivers to Hellpods.
My cape is orange.
Oh yeah?
Her cape is orange.
My cape is orange.
I mean, look at me compared to Zeller.
So you know I'm the richer one here.
Don't come here.
You paid the win.
You paid real money.
You're a super citizen.
You paid.
Wait, why is my title a super citizen?
I changed it.
You're trying to hide the shame.
No, no, no.
Look, look, look.
I have a better title.
Super Sheef Prime.
I'm a Super Sheef Prime.
He's a sheep.
Twitch Prime.
Alright, go to TokiBird at Twitch and give Twitch Prime.
Okay, dude.
Listen, Twitch Priming RPR.
Go to TokiBird at Twitch and put your Twitch Prime there.
You're stealing from smaller streamers now?
That's kind of lame.
What do you mean?
You've been streaming longer than me.
I started two weeks ago.
Yeah, yeah.
Two weeks ago, yeah.
You're still a big streamer though.
I'm not a stream either, man.
Wow.
Wait, Han, what's your Twitch channel?
What's your Twitch channel?
Twitch.tv slash HanGa.
Yeah, guys, you can Twitch Prime there.
No, don't worry about it.
I don't stream.
Wait, where's my...
Where's the one I got?
Look, now I have two orbital attacks.
For this one, we're going to be destroying fabricators.
So we need to have all the destruction that we could possibly get.
Hell yeah, leave it to me.
I got Eagle Cluster.
I got the better Eagle Cluster, so...
It's not a competition, man.
Hell yeah, it is.
Now it is.
Well, you have two clusters.
That sounds extremely promising.
I have a cluster too.
Three.
And I both have Eagle Cluster.
Yeah, it's great.
What can go wrong?
Boom.
Boom, boom, boom, boom.
Boom, boom.
Lisa.
Alright, let's destroy.
Oh, there's already one there.
Orange cape.
If I didn't destroy any active...
Whoa, holy shit.
Holy shit, why they're already here, yo?
That's a lot.
Oh, fuck.
Careful, careful, careful.
Wait, that's not what I wanted.
Shoot the guys back.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, shit.
I need to grab my gun.
I need to grab my anti-personnel.
Wait, who the fuck activated the patrol?
Was it me?
Grabbing my anti-personnel.
I'm gonna destroy purple.
See you guys.
Alright.
Are we spawning this shit?
Fuck.
I'm waiting for my...
I got me machine gun.
Oh, fuck.
What is that?
Why are there so many of them?
Just run to where Hani's running.
Just go, Hani.
I missed.
Yeah?
It don't really seem like you got us.
It's okay.
I actually...
I actually got us.
I got you guys this time.
Oh, I hit it!
Nice.
I did it.
I'm heading back.
She says that as she keeps running in the opposite direction of where she's supposed to be running.
I'm coming over now.
I'm heading over now.
Look, it's the...
It's the end result, not the journey.
Oh, shit.
I thought it was the journey that matters, not the end result.
No, it's the end result that matters.
Yeah, that's true.
I'm heading over.
My stamina's not as great right now.
Land mine!
Let me pop this shit.
Off to the west.
Alright.
Wait, Arpyr, where are you going?
Wait, there's trenches here.
Uh, side... side mission.
Oh, oh, oh, something hit me.
Something fucking hit me.
There's artillery.
There's artillery hitting me.
Careful, careful, careful.
I'm coming over.
Wait, we have turrets here.
We have turrets here.
We can use these.
There's turrets here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I'm gonna get the turrets.
We got ten minutes.
I don't know if these turrets are really gonna be that useful, though.
Okay, they're not that useful.
They're not that useful.
I'm heading over to hide.
Yeah.
Oh, god.
Uh, uh, I don't know if you wanna come towards me.
Yeah, I don't know anymore.
There's so many of them here.
Leave me.
It's time to go solo.
No, don't go solo.
I don't need you anymore.
No!
Excellent documentation.
Okay, so we stick together and finish that one.
I'm gonna finish one here.
Wait, there's a railgun here.
There's a railgun on me.
Okay, I cannot...
Oh, get away.
I'm sure nothing can go wrong if you guys are together, right?
I got the big one.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I have one stim left.
Everything's fine.
Oh, hey!
Oh, no!
Zeller and Dokki, you guys stick together.
Han, you get the one.
And I get the one.
And then we'll maybe get all of them.
In ten minutes.
Oh, my god.
There's so many people!
Zeller!
Huh?
Reinforcements!
Yeah, yeah, I gotta send you back in, eh?
Get your bitch ass back in.
I can't see shit!
Get your bitch ass back in here.
I'm here.
Don't worry.
I have my shotgun.
I can throw a Gatling gun for us.
Ammo.
Oh, yeah, that's like...
Northwards.
Purple ping.
I got you, Zeller.
Thank you, yo.
Let's go, go, go, go, go, go.
Wait, is that a tank?
No, it's not.
We're good.
Are we good?
Let's go purple ping.
I think so.
Purple ping.
Oh, yeah, yeah, we're heading.
Yeah, don't worry.
Zeller and I are heading over.
We're here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, we're heading over.
I should grab it.
I'm gonna...
Go grab a machine gun.
Give me a sec.
You're in green.
Don't need help.
My machine gun's coming over.
In 12 seconds.
You go up there for me, Zeller.
I'm gonna grab my machine gun.
Oh, yeah, go.
You go grab that, girl.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Whoa!
There's so many of them.
It's a cannon.
Oh, I'm having a rough time.
Time for me to destroy that thing, I guess.
Where's the cannon?
Oh, I see the cannon.
Leave it to me!
Leave it to us!
We have ego cluster!
Zeller, use your ego cluster!
I got you!
Does the ego cluster even destroy those things?
I don't know.
Maybe I didn't throw it far enough.
Maybe you didn't throw it far.
Don't worry!
I'm gonna throw my ego cluster, too!
Oh, it's jammed.
Never mind.
What do you mean it's jammed?
Apparently it's one ego cluster per person.
Oh no...
Okay, I'm getting close!
Leave it to me!
We're getting closer!
I'm so stupid!
Oh my god.
I got you.
We did it!
We broke it!
Nice!
We just gotta get out of here.
Ping south!
Alright, we got this.
We gotta go south.
I'm trying to get to the utility.
Wait, we gotta...
We gotta grab Zeller!
Gotcha, gotcha.
Okay.
I'm gonna throw an ego cluster.
Oh god.
Oh, I couldn't grab it!
Oh no...
It's okay, we have 16!
Guys!
I'm on a tank!
Fuck!
Here I am watching RPR and soloing the fucking tower.
I'm gonna miss it!
I'm on a tank!
They're doing everything to me!
They're doing all the unthinkable things to me!
I got the tank!
They were doing all unthinkable things to me!
I'm here!
We're okay!
I need a resupply!
War never changes!
I got it, I got it, I got it!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh my goodness!
We all bunched up together.
Nothing will happen to us, right?
If we don't bunch up together.
Nothing.
Nothing bad is gonna happen.
Alright, I'm gonna...
I'm gonna grab my...
Maybe my sentry gun can do stuff.
Oh, okay.
Oh, kinda hard.
Wait, I can do an eagle cluster now!
Ugh!
But do we need it though?
Do we need that eagle cluster?
I don't know, but there's like three things going on in there.
Southwaters, we have five minutes guys!
Come on!
Five minutes!
Where's the extraction point?
South, south, south!
Okay, okay, okay.
Right on me.
I'm gonna start it.
Alright, alright.
I'm here.
Four minutes, we gotta survive.
Alright.
We can do that.
I got the big boy!
I threw my gundling thing already.
Oh wait, I need to grab my...
I'm gonna grab my anti-tank.
I got the anti-tank as well.
I'll be there in a second.
Okay.
I have more eagle cluster!
Don't worry!
Oh no.
What do you mean oh no?
It has been helpful!
Yeah, for the other team.
That is a lie.
That is a fucking lie.
I'm a truther, nothing but a truther.
That is a lie.
Guys.
Are you okay?
I'll be there in a minute.
Don't worry.
Zeller and I were defending you.
We're defending you at the point.
We're just standing here.
We're doing great guys.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Look, we're killing so many over here.
Oh my god, we're killing so many over here.
Look at us go!
I have anti-personnel.
You guys got any of them stims?
Yeah, I got four stims left.
Can you stim me?
Where are you?
You're too far man.
You're too far.
I think you gotta stim yourself bro.
I don't have stims.
Say pretty please.
I've been looking for one.
You're fine.
I'd rather die than beg you for a fucking stim, Bucky.
I'd rather fucking die.
I guess you die then.
I guess you die.
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you so much.
That's a real homie.
I got an achievement for that.
I'm out!
You are special.
Spawn me in.
Look at all the loot!
Wow.
Oh shit!
Killing me!
Ew!
I can't breathe!
It was an accident!
I swear!
Please!
Oh god!
No!
It's revenge!
Why would you kill me?
They're here, they're here, they're here!
They're here!
Yay!
I wanna have some fun too, come on!
Yeah, you wanna have some fun?
No, I feel awful.
Yeah, we're just having fun.
Beep, beep, beep, beep, beep.
Wait, I can bring out my galleon.
Let's see.
I'm gonna bring out the Eagle Nepal Nail Strike.
Oh god, where?
Right over there, right in the center.
Oh my god!
Eagle, eagle, eagle strike, eagle strike.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god.
Oh look, look, it's gonna hit them all!
Look, it's gonna hit them all!
Look at that!
Oh my god, that was so hot.
Holy shit!
We got two!
Yeah, it definitely killed everybody.
You killed yourself.
I told you beforehand.
Look, look how many I killed!
Look at you go!
Han was one of the people on the list.
I was behind cover too.
I got the big boy!
Oh no!
What the fuck was that for?
I'm doing it!
15 seconds!
15!
I got the anti-tank boy.
Nice.
TNT minus 10 seconds, clear landing zone.
Oh, where is it?
Oh, we're good, it's coming in 5 seconds!
I got the anti-tank boy!
Oh my goodness.
The anti-tank boy is what exactly?
The anti-tank is like one shot.
Just remove that.
Oh, the rocket?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, it's coming down!
It's coming down!
Leave it to me!
Eagle strike!
Right on you!
No, no, no, no, no, no.
We have to get it if it's right on us.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no!
No, no, no, no, no!
I'm in!
Oh god, I'm running, I'm running, I'm running!
Not real!
I'm getting in, I'm getting in!
I'm getting in!
Oh, we did it!
Let's go!
Yay!
Oh, easiest game of my life.
I'm so stressed.
You need to see that from my pubic.
I said, Eagle strike.
I got you bro, eagle strike.
And my whole screen turned red from the laser.
No, I was like, I got you, eagle strike!
On you, on you!
Dude, my whole screen, because I was inside the red laser, my whole screen turned red.
That's when I died.
Someone clip that, man.
I can't believe we successfully extracted, holy shit.
Someone clip that shit, please.
Holy fuck!
We actually did it!
We all got extracted for once.
Oh my god.
We did it!
That was so good.
We should LG on Bug Island.
Oh shit.
You wanna go back to bugs?
Yes, we should LG on the bugs.
What LG means?
Last name.
Last game on the bugs.
Life is good.
We ended.
Oh my god.
Let's look at team damage real quick.
Alright.
I think we sort of know who has the most team damage.
Can you guys see my finger guns?
Heck yeah.
Trust me, not me this time.
Oh look!
Zero!
25!
What?
25?
Zero!
Wait, how did you...
So I told you it wasn't me, RPR!
It said you killed me.
No, it's a zero friendly fire!
I regret nothing.
It can't be me!
It's a zero friendly fire!
I saw you shoot the rocket.
Yeah, but it didn't hit anybody.
It hit me in the face.
Are you trying to say stats are lying?
Are you trying to say the stats are lying?
Yes.
Whoa.
I'm gonna go.
I'm gonna be a medic now.
A medic?
That's gonna be fucking funny.
Yeah, I'll have six teams.
Wait, it's not a medic if you heal yourself.
It's not a medic if you heal yourself.
I'm a medic for me, not for you guys.
Seller, did you buy the bow pass stuff?
You didn't customize your items.
Press R.
Go to R and then go to click the war button.
The first thing you see.
Yeah.
And then you just unlock it.
Okay.
Yeah, you can get new health meds.
How do I equip it on, though?
I look so cool.
If you unlock it, there's like an equip button.
Oh, they look all so ugly.
It's fine.
Oh, shit, you're full orange.
Oh my god, Dok, you look terrible.
What do you mean?
I'm orange.
Yo, nice cape.
Yeah, look at my cape.
Woo!
Alright, let's go to Erato Prime.
Nice.
Wait, we can now play on extreme.
Oh no!
Maybe we shouldn't.
What can go wrong with me?
Isn't extreme bugs the one with the big one?
They're all pretty big.
What do you mean?
Oh, you haven't seen big.
Oh, what?
It's a big bug.
The double B big bug.
Alright.
Oh, gee.
The eagle strike on your ass is...
the perfect callout you could have done there.
Actually.
It was literally inside of me.
My whole screen turned red.
It's crazy.
Woah, where are you going?
Woah, you look so dusty.
I got my eagle strike.
My...
Alright.
Readied.
I got everything I need.
Ooh, vitality ready up.
Alright.
Did you put the help on one?
I forgot.
We don't need it.
It's not like we're on extreme or anything.
Right?
I kind of panicked because everybody else was ready.
And I was the only one who wasn't ready.
So I clicked ready because I wanted to get people to wait.
It's okay, Han.
We'll just go with this whole plan.
We'll just run into half of the ammo that we're supposed to run.
Yeah.
That'll be okay.
I don't know.
Oh, it's the holes one.
Oh, why do we spawn in front of people?
Oh.
Woah.
No.
Oh god.
There's a big one right behind us.
That's an interesting spawn.
Oh god.
He's still alive.
I'm nading.
Oh my god.
His ass is on fire.
Oh god.
Okay, I'm going to spawn in a machine gun real fast.
That's a wonderful idea.
He died.
Yep, I killed him.
Okay.
Wait, I just...
There's another one.
Yeah, I'll deal with him.
Grabbing my machine gun.
Got it.
Show your butt.
Show your ass.
Nice.
Okay.
I'm gonna...
I'm gonna fucking...
Order in a machine gun as well.
Oh.
One second.
Wait, nade this thing?
I'll nade it.
Move.
Wait, nade what?
I'm nading this door.
There's a door?
Oh, there is a door.
There's a flamethrower in here.
Oh no.
Except for...
It's good that there's two of them using it.
But yeah, it's great.
No, I'm not using it.
It's Doki.
So I'm fine.
You know, she's got that POV.
You or Doki using it is still not good.
What do you mean?
It's content.
Look at this.
It's definitely content.
It's not good though.
Look, I did it.
Let's go.
Oh no, there's a stalker nest.
Oh, don't worry.
I have flamethrower.
I'm heading over.
Yeah, run into that nest.
Come on, go, go, go.
I gotta delete that stalker nest or we're gonna die.
I'm gonna go, I'm gonna go.
I'm coming over, I'm coming over.
Fire is coming.
Don't worry.
I'm coming over.
Where's the second son?
Yeah, where's the second son?
How many sons do you have?
What?
Oh, big man coming from the back.
Oh, shit.
Where is that?
Right behind us.
Oh, shit.
Oh, you're right.
Oh, fuck.
He's tanky.
Let's just lead him over to RPR.
We lead him over to RPR.
That's the plan.
Oh, my god.
Holy shit.
I'm shooting him in the ass.
I'm fucking him in the ass.
He's looking at me.
Ah, fuck.
Okay, I was...
You did it.
You did it, Zoe.
I was a distraction.
But I got him though, didn't I?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's good.
I was a distraction.
I'm...
I'm killing these small ones.
It's a big boy!
Why can I not...
destroy this local rail?
Or layer?
No!
You got any nades, boys?
I'm okay.
No, I'm not.
I am not okay.
I am not okay right now.
Okay.
Please.
Somebody!
I can't see you!
I just saw her die in her own flame cover.
There was like six of them!
There's a bio-titan over where I was.
There's a bio-titan?
Yeah.
Zalurza, pick up my flame flower!
Pick it up!
I am... I am getting fucked!
I am...
I am getting fucked!
Wait, am I landing on my flame flower?
Yeah!
Pick it up yourself!
Okay, I got it.
Nice, nice, nice.
Wait, where is it?
We gotta close more terminate holes.
Where's my flame flower?
It's behind you somewhere.
Did you take it?
Nope, I have a railgun.
Oh, I have it!
We are actually in a desert and we can't see shit.
We can't see shit.
Oh, yeah, this is a terrible map.
Holy moly.
This is what driving with an astigmatism looks like.
Wait, there's mosquitos too?
Oh, don't get bit by one of them.
You're gonna die if you get bit by one over here.
Yeah, I don't think they have cures for whatever disease they have here.
I don't know how many nades.
Can you roll the shit up?
Yeah, I have.
I spawned in.
Oh my god, I got...
AHHHHH!
Nice.
Thanks, guys.
I got the anti-tank kill.
Fast travel.
Okay, more holes here.
Oh, it just blocked it, I think.
Nice.
Woah, woah, woah.
I'm reloading.
There's one behind you, Han.
There's three behind us.
Behind us.
Oh, it's this thing.
I'm coming.
There's a giant mushroom.
Wait, what the fuck is this fire-spitting shit?
I got the spore.
I did!
Okay.
I need a resupply soon.
I'm running out of flames.
No.
We'll let her have a fucking...
Yes, thank you!
I got you!
Nice flame.
It's not burning alive.
I can hear it breathing.
Yeah, I can hear it.
I hate the community.
Don't worry about it.
That wasn't my fault.
I can't hit this guy's leg, bro.
It's okay, I can just burn it.
I can just burn it.
Oh my god, he hates me.
Okay, I don't have flames.
I'm gonna call a resupply.
I got it with the anti-tank killer.
Nice, nice, nice.
You didn't kill him.
Well, nearly.
Just got rid of his shield.
I got another one.
Don't worry, we have another anti-tank.
Fuck!
Okay, he's dead.
Nice.
I got more flames.
I'm good.
Nice, nice, nice.
Alright, where do we go?
Five more minutes to get like...
Four more... wait.
Five more.
Oh my god, too many symbols.
Math?
Yes, addition is really hard.
Okay, I'll split up.
I'm getting rest.
I'm...
Zeller and I are coming over to RPR because we think he needs the most help.
Okay.
Yeah, yeah.
Han Solo doesn't need mine.
I can handle this.
That's my name, baby.
Yeah, that's why he's Han Solo and RPR is R2-D2.
He needs more than two people with him.
Yeah, that's why there's the two.
The only thing I need from you guys is your guys' nades.
Because I'm out of nades.
Leave it to me!
Throw them in the orange holes.
Oh, this one here?
Yeah, yeah.
That one and this one next to me.
Okay, I got you.
Yeah, throw in that hole.
You got this, Zeller.
Fire in the hole.
And this one here.
I got this one.
Fire in the hole.
We did it!
We need one more.
Han, you got that last one?
I'm going for it.
Okay, that was easy.
We had bugs.
Yeah, I know, right?
Nothing against us humans.
After the robot orientation missions, this is so easy now.
Hell yeah.
Yeah!
You guys haven't met a hive queen yet, have you?
No.
Is there a hive queen here?
Oh, is it that little slug looking bitch?
No, it's a four.
It's like a massive bug.
Well, they're all bugs.
It's gigantic.
Yeah, they're all bugs.
It's like gigantic, though.
Wait, is there a hive queen in this map?
I don't know if one of them will spawn here.
Let's go kill her then.
Easy.
Yeah, let's kill her.
I don't know if it will spawn in this difficulty.
Hey, more holes here if you guys have nades.
Alright.
Oh, there's flying ones.
They're coming over.
Oh, there's a lot of holes here.
And a lot of big guys.
Guys, no!
They're all getting up!
Oh no.
Guys, it's okay.
Oh, she died.
So I can grab my flamethrower.
Han died?
Yep, I sacrificed myself.
It's alright.
You wanted to die so you're closer to us when we extraction.
Pretty much.
Death only brings us closer.
Exactly!
Yeah!
War brings us closer.
Are we coming in now?
Okay!
Where's the big guys?
They probably spawned you.
Nice.
Okay, I'm gonna land on them.
Oh, I squished one.
Wait, I'm gonna throw one.
Can you guys plug roles?
Yep, yep, yep, yep.
Where's my flamethrower?
Samples?
Nice, nice, nice.
Where the fuck is my flamethrower?
You have two minutes, so it's probably good then.
Yep, let's go, let's go.
North, east, north, east.
Punisher.
Oh, there you go.
We're heading over.
I have no more stims.
I have two stims.
I'm running over.
Calling down a sentry!
Okay.
Oh no, I just saw a big guy spawn.
I'm throwing an E.T.
guys.
I'm way behind you guys, but I'm coming over.
Alright, we'll look for you.
Oh, there's a big guy right after you!
Maybe I won't look for you.
Oh shit, oh shit, oh shit.
Oh fuck!
If you walk over here, I'll get rid of him.
Guys, he's like blocking me.
It's okay.
Come up here, come up here.
I need them coming over.
No, the eagle!
You threw a nade on her.
This is the wall of fire.
Now they can't come over, see?
I'm okay.
I planned that, I planned that.
Now they're all getting burned.
No, no, no, no, no.
Nothing bad happened to me.
I'm okay.
I don't think we got it in time.
Han, there's a lot of red X's.
Alright.
Oh, there's some coming over now.
Can you call a resupply?
I'm out of ammo, basically.
Thank you.
Alright, I'm gonna throw a gatling.
Up, up, up.
Oh my god.
They're doing their part.
We're all doing our part.
I threw my gatling in.
Fuck, this guy's so tanky.
He's like...
Oh, that's a big guy.
Big guy's over to your left.
I killed one of the...
Fuck, this guy's so tanky.
I'm gonna try and get the flying ones.
Where's the big guy?
Big guy is down.
Big guy's down.
Oh no, nevermind.
There's another big guy.
He's dead.
I'm stuck.
I'm flamethrowing.
It's okay.
We're good.
Reloading.
There's another big guy.
Another big guy.
He's coming to me.
I'm shooting him in the van.
I'm shooting him.
He's burning.
He's breathing.
You hear the weirdest stuff.
Really?
Yeah.
Where are you from?
Oh, there's a Hive Queen.
Oh, this guy's massive.
Wait, is that the Hive Queen?
Yes.
I'm reloading.
Okay.
I reload.
Oh, what the...
What?
Oh, I...
I killed her.
Guys, I got stomped on.
Miles.
I didn't...
I killed her.
Nice.
Oh, these fucking...
Small crabs ate me.
I didn't know that.
We need to call them in.
But there's a lot on us.
The destroyer has left orbit.
Bring us back.
Shuttle to your shuttle tier.
Remember us.
Remember what we did for all of you.
Don't forget about us.
Are you good, hun?
I'm good.
Oh, my lord.
Oh, my god.
Just another day of work.
I can't believe we saw the Hive Queen.
We saw and I got stomped on it.
If I hit it.
It's actually called the Bile Titan.
But I keep calling her Hive Queen for some reason.
I can't believe it.
It was an honor.
I shot like a cannon in her.
And then as soon as I finished shooting a cannon in her, there's like three little crab looking guys jumped on my ass.
And I just blew and died.
How dare you cannon the queen.
How dare you.
They're like, aww, beyond me.
My queen.
My sacrifice was not in vain.
Four stars.
Woo!
Nice!
That's almost like a five star.
A mournful victory.
Remember us.
Look how many samples I got us.
Oh, my god.
I'm the king.
Holy crap.
Holy shit.
I'm going around and collecting.
Wait, did your badge update?
On the bottom left.
Yeah, it did.
It's back to super citizen.
Why does it keep changing?
It knows you're...
Super citizen.
Pay to win.
Dark Veedle looking ass.
No friendly fire damage.
Next one for him is going to be senior citizen.
We did so good.
We learned.
We did it.
We fired so many.
How are you guys not firing any shots?
I don't get it.
What the fuck?
Because I'm shooting big rockets.
Because we're shooting to kill.
Not shooting the floor.
He's shooting big rockets.
You're only shooting small rockets.
I'm shooting pellet guns.
GG's guys.
I had fun.
That was so fun.
I'm glad we...
Thanks for joining me.
Thank you guys.
I had a lot of fun.
Doing our parts.
The favorite game we had for me was the first one.
What do you mean?
My favorite game was the...
The game before this.
Nah.
Seeing Zeller land on Han.
And then pick up his scarver cannon.
And shoot Docky in the ass.
Was 100% a highlight.
At the very beginning.
Just a double kill.
I landed on Zeller too.
One way I landed on Zeller.
Right after you.
GG guys.
GG.
I'm so happy to play Helldivers 2 with all of you.
That was fun.
You guys are so fun with my squad.
I know why you spent 10 hours on it last night.
Holy shit.
Let's do it again sometime.
Hell yeah for sure.
GG's.
I'm gonna talk to my chat a little bit.
But thank you guys for joining.
Let's do this again.
Salute to the captain.
Wait captain.
This is my ship.
Stop left.
This is operated by RPR.
I am the captain.
Aye aye captain.
Oh he left.
Alright.
See you guys.
Bye bye.
Let me swap real quick.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Oh no.
Leaks.
Member leaks.
I forgot to hide that.
Sorry guys.
A little bit of a sneak peek for the charity auction.
I'm sorry.
For...
Saturday.
Um...
That was really fun.
That was so fun.
I'm really happy to be able to play with Hans, Zelian, RPR today.
And uh...
It has been a joy.
To play with the three.
Um...
Play with some new friends today.
Sorry to the ones...
For the people in NA.
Thank you all for the superchats!
Holy shit!
Affiliate, thank you for the magenta soup!
Thank you, thank you!
This group was so fun.
Hope you guys get to collab more in the future.
I hope so too!
I hope so too.
I definitely had a great time.
Thank you again for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you!
I can't believe Zeller spent like 200 plus dollars trying to get L-timers 2 to work.
Like, you guys don't understand.
It was so funny because like...
He couldn't get it to work on the first account.
So we're like, just make a new account and do like family share.
And then it didn't work because it's like region locked.
So then we're like, okay, buy like buy steam gift card.
And then he couldn't buy steam gift card and add it on.
And it didn't work because like for some reason he tried multiple times to purchase it.
And then the account got locked.
So then we're like, okay, Han.
You buy the game for him.
And then give the account to Zeller.
And it worked.
Holy shit.
Oh my god.
It was like a lot of back and forth.
It was so funny.
But yeah, everybody.
I'm gonna rest now.
It's been a long, long day.
So I hope you guys had a fun time watching.
As always, everybody stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And then I'll see you guys in the next video.
Bye!
And if you stay up for me, head to bed.
Because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time everybody.
Bye guys!
Bye!